[Musique]
bienvenue à sans filtre le podcast où on
parle de ce qu'on veut que nos invités
dati site super h 30 avec madame plantes
cette semaine sans filtre est encore une
fois présenté par paul islip pour les
slicks une compagnie québécoise qui
fabrique des matelots 100% morial dans
le respect de l'environnement et dans
les plus hauts standards de qualité
police les parents déjà parlé et offre
une garantie 6 200 nuits décès dont vous
étiez un matelas vous l'amener chez vous
vous aimez pas ça pour le renvoyer
personne charles vous êtes remboursé
tout est beau trente jours 30 nuit
d'essey en fait sur les oreillers
voulais essayer vous les avez pas vous
les renvoyer mais honnêtement on se le
dit vous allez vous les achetez puis
jamais vous allez les renvoyer parce que
c'est de la bombe
dom on danse sur les oreilles et
policiers ouais ouais moi j'ai depuis
qu'ils nous envoyer police libre s'est
rendue mais auriez principe pour le
j'avais deux reilly qui étaient bons
standards mais sur le son comme son
sacoche le pid enfoncé qui peut les
mettre à la hausse et passe sans que tu
veux ouais bah qui tue le même intérêt
que parfaitement pic d'or comme un bébé
ça fit pour tous les types de sommeil
si vous voulez vous procurer un matelas
police lit où on ne riez pas ici pour un
code promo pour vous autres vous inciter
à faire le switch parce qu'on sait qu'un
bon matelas c'est la chose mais moins
pour votre qualité de ce même si vous
utilisez le code promo sans filtre 70 au
moment du check out
là vous allez sauver 70 dollars sur
votre mac losc est plutôt considérable
et si vous utilisez code promo sans
filtre 10 au check out lors d'un achat
de riez vous allez survie de 10 de l'or
sont un oreiller
encore une fois très considérable sinon
un énorme podcast cette semaine qu'elle
adore honnêtement non mais honnêtement
c'est un jour de grève le d'objectifs
on est vraiment content de l'avoir de
l'avoir réalisé
si on oublie de parler de la ligue 2 go
le comme attaquer et un gameplay si je
veux compter la savate young
on a fait un vidéo vanille après minute
vidéo et dia stx et de la mare ce que
vous faites
puis je vous gage que vous réussirez
jamais avoir ma carte puis si vous avez
macworld
je vous promets de m'abonner à la
spéciale sans pièces par mois mais moins
de steed potable
non mais ça joke non mais vraiment
honoré puis un gars tellement généreux
et puis une ici bâti accepté puis
gentiment
c'est une super belle diction longues
discussions la bad est plein de sujets
le mécanisme et son passage à joe hogan
quoi d'autre qu'on ne parlait pas la fin
mais on a parlé du moma gad elmaleh qui
copient des jack simpson mike d'être
copie comique c'est lui qui explosent et
les valeurs des gags mais mythique non
médicaux baisse on est bien fiers puis
ben content d'avoir réussi ma maison
puis si vous aimez le sans-fil podcast
encore une fois vous pouvez nous suivre
sur pétrone nous encourager en fait du
contenu exclusif on répond à vos
questions
comme vous allez le voir dans le podcast
avec mike on prend des questions nos
membres et une pour les poser aux
invités on a justement que répondu à une
question d'un homme impétueux et ensuite
commenté sur le podcast abonnez-vous à
notre chaîne si vous écoutez sur balles
à dos les seniors et nss 5 étoiles ça
fait un long bout de chemin
cela permet à plus de monde dans le
podcast puis s'ébranle un tour la plus
longue qu'on a fait et veut la plus
longtemps qu'à y est on va annoncer que
bientôt le décor de changer s'il est on
va annoncer en fait que c'était le
dernier podcast contourner chez nous
combinez majeur peut-être que ce soit le
dernier convoi willis mais c'est le
dernier qui a tourné ces derniers quand
on aimerait savoir huge la gagne ça va
être énorme on va avoir des grosses
annonces à faire bientôt on parle on
parle on pas non si vous avez cliqué
pour écouter mais correct sans plus
attendre
bon écoute bon broadcast
[Musique]
wright c'est parti yes mike ward merci
d'être là d'un fait plaisait elle fait
vraiment un plaisir que tu vois le puits
théo un peu le parrain du podcast au
québec on s'assume un seul monsieur
s'est rappelé l'eba de carson en
quarantaine au québec sauf l'eau
maintenant commence à la morphine
les grosses compagnies font mes yeux
c'est le futur les radios s'est produit
pour longtemps mais moi j'ai eu l'année
passée n'ont pas fait une couple
d'années dans le temps qu éric salvail
est encore un humain que les fata si
j'avais été un parti bell média qui
avait un des vendeurs de pub qui m'avait
dit a dit la radio ça va mourir une
couple d'années un vendeur le public en
est à part n'a fait mieux taille et à sa
brosse loi mais on était la radio et les
pâtes qu'un steak au dessus quand tu
fais de la longue route dont tu mets ton
de cette voie pharmacie de danton
charles de bonheur un pinceau fakty je
pense la radio la radio musicale et plus
en santé parce que tu peux pas payer mes
temps justement de savoir pharmacie le
type en bribes de conversation s'arrête
à chaque fois que j'écoute quand
j'écoute la radio du coach juste des
radios musicales moins moche pitt ocha
non parce qu'il ya de quoi tu fais chier
tu es vu que la radio parlée ce commun
pas de 15 en deux fois mais avec 1000
pub avec wally et c'est surtout le temps
de tout juste radio canepa de pub mais
des fois il parle de deux trucs que
toutankhamon charge souvent je le mets
au 98,5 mais je maîtrise de ses coûts la
météo trafic est il mieux même si ça
vous aimez se disait que ça sent les
trafics à 4 heures tout est bouché
puis la température on a tout sur nos
téléphones
la température dans nos autos
serra qui risque à tabac besoin de
savoir leur la radio et on dirait c'est
du monde qui vivent dans nos verres
d'alcool
ça fait quand même temps que le gorille
de dc le gode ben ça devait 2000
tu avais des gitans podcast où j'avais
commencé sous écoute en baisse la
première version en 2011
ouais qui a précisé le faisait parce que
les points je le faisais par skype puis
j'avais arrêté parce tout le monde m'a
insulté tout le monde passait le monde
faisait quand on estime d'autres sont un
incompétent un ton ton monte à jeter
comme c'est moi tu sais pas c'est parce
qu'un choix souvent adressé le monde
m'insultait comme les tabards n'est
souvent et insultait maintenant la
qualité
il a ainsi eu la qualité pas bonne mais
c'était parce les marais savait pas des
bonnes que moi j'avais acheté trop la
tâche qu'il y avait des menaces et des
pics bourg que y amener de la halle à
tarbes auch il manque pour connaître
toutes les mêmes sorties mais l'odm
n'avait pas de bonnes connexions
internet logé fait
or qui faute de jarry niger commence en
2001 2012 2013 un studio j'avais loué un
loft pour ça je me disais et encaissa me
coûte c'est ça me coûte 500 pièces par
épisode plus le loft plus que j'ai fait
ça n'a pas de sens quand quand le
bordaient la partie j'ai fait en jeu va
ramener sous écoute la dernière version
à date de 2015
ok ouais c'est fou quand même source
avait aussi des justes des humoristes
choisi c'est le même principe
c'est tellement mais même principe j'ai
eu au début c'était moins drôle que
c'est là parce que moi je voulais pas un
podcast du monte au début même je vais
penser de façon devant public
mais je voulais pas que le public
contrôler les discussions voulais que ça
soit des discussions mais mon à l'autre
des discussions de loge dans le fond
mais un quand je lis commence au bordel
vu que je n'avais fait comme une
trentaine j'avais le temps que je
voulais donner qui je me laisserai pas
influencer par le public puis même mes
premiers invités
il faut quand le chantier en chute
rocheuses et regarde pas obligé de
vendre et de vendre dans la foi c'est
rien mais surtout pour vous écouter le
monde qui essaie d'être drôle
marché des mauvaises habitudes comme
aulas a moins besoin mais la plupart
tout ligne mais l'hymne ce qu'ils ont
été mauvais après vingt minutes ils
contrainte appris ça jusqu'à ce que tu
es débriefing après m mais je dis tout
le temps là la seule fois que je lisais
un animal rustique j'ai eu c'est yannick
de martino lucide qui a amené y avaient
fait le pas de casque répétés au après
dima midi c'est tout cas rien que
j'avais fait pour de vrai et le pire
mais je descends un gag marqué c'est là
que j remarque c'est là que j'ai comme
complique
je suis un vieux monsieur était tenu de
la crise et c'est mon cas mais ça va
j'avais déjà baissé ses discussions avec
ma blonde l'autre fois je me disais dos
ils ont taillé me souvienne mike ward
était pertinent pitié du monde ta
génération qu'il était bleu 15 ans ils
sont plus nécessairement maintenant mais
toi tu les restes étiquetés comme tu
étais jeune dans l'âme fait que
j'imagine si jean-luc sont la relève qui
a réuni qu'elles sont et shon mais que
pour eux je voudrais y ont grandi comme
moi j'ai 28 ans puis comme j'ai grandi
en ayant comme une idole ou comme
quelqu'un qui était qui et l appui que
dans l'humour surtout le mais ces gens
là c'est cet été comme moi mais on
dirait c'est le fait que j'aie jamais
c'est plus facile rester au niveau que
je suis parce que c'est pas comme étant
un homme est tombé comme les idées ont
été ou comme les joselois martin matte t
ça c'est impossible rester aussi
longtemps dit que moi je suis jamais au
sommet des sondages en body ne se
présentent pas de cas ça ne t'a pas mal
à mener ou sa mère mais chaque ça montre
vraiment nous ce que je voulais être
parce moi j'aime pas à être connu mais
j'ai besoin d'être connue pour rampe les
messages mois puis sous écoute la beauté
de tout ce que je fais quelque chose qui
100% moi même un pige rejoint autant
demande que si j'avais un show avait
attendait n'est pas de casque de ses 1
million par mois en une station
moi je suis vraiment content parce que
c'est simplement audio on compte youtube
là on compte lié aux tout petits c'est
incroyable pour le québec c'est démesuré
- meilleur c'est jay jay à peu près cent
mille personnes qui écoutent lille dans
l'eau d'un million de fois fait beaucoup
de monde qui défendent l'accord glace
outils doc y écouteurs député de cinq
épisodes y écoute en libye les excès qui
deviennent mythique est marrant il se
passe des côtes - je suis vraiment
chanceux team moi je pense pas que de la
chance le coeur cessé de parce c'est le
truc je trouve de toutes les passions de
succès c'est pas abandonné tu commencé
au début la faim qui ce système pas des
commentaires ou si j'avais eu quelqu'un
qui savait ce qu'il faisait
sernhac serait rendu à épisodes 2002 5
mais bon au début ce ski free quand tu
commences clos mais vous on vous avait
déjà participé méthyle la part des pages
et j'avais j'avais un petit texto du
monde qui écoutait plus gros et puis
encore ce jour c'est le premier était ok
on attend ici on ne descend du pi
tranquillement au monde qui nous annonce
base de personnes qui nous suivent
mais c'est quand même emmené ses sites
mans comparé aux chiffres de la tv c'est
ça les premières fois j'avais tendance à
face je faisais en salle tv que la radio
ou ainsi pas pourquoi j'ai vu que les
chiffres de la radio était dispo
vraiment le sport la télévente tout le
temps de lyon 1 million de cotes
d'écouté comme j'ai juste maintenant dix
mille personnes sont pas gros mais après
j'ai repensé en termes de salle chacun
astuces et dit stern saint denis
j'allume mon ordi puisse comme si
j'avais été un demi centre bell de plein
quand je me suis même resté motivé
dans son podcast ceux des fois ça de
cette pop sucette
cette réflexion dans l'attenté que du
manque critique et j'aurais millions
personnes qui m'ont jamais jamais jamais
mais là le défaut de ses côtes
puis je pense c'est le fait aussi que
moi j'en papier plus souvent tiendra les
1er et maryse qui venait dans l'art
tactile faisant chute avec mike d'un bar
personnes à la seule l'allemande
il semble que sont les lyonnais qui font
plus attention
c'est la première fois que louis
morissette qui était venu d'en reparler
parler comment le gouvernement harper le
voulaient l'emmener où l'avait emmené en
cours à cause du bye bye toutes les
magouilles avec le gouvernement paiera
du week end
j'étais comme rien n'était mais c'est
surtout une discussion skype qui mène à
l'époque selon montebourg est un peu les
chiffres inventés par un ver plus un
ennemi plus penser que ces sacrées
championnes du monde comme louis t quand
yann aussi mutatis il annonça sous
écoute à 20 tout le monde est un peu tôt
qui est dit est pas un plus haut à steak
et autres invités filets 0-1 maladie
plus n'était pas comme pas à l'aise a
parlé plus tôt fait oui tu avais plus
axé story avec avec sous écoute d'autre
qu'un gros on a parti le bal gascon des
sites avant qu'on ait des chiffres qui
était intéressant pour les peintures les
commandites ont checké des façons de
rendre ce viable pour que nous on prenne
notre table qu'on le fasse fureur
quelques ondées commencé à partir du
pétrole on a cherché des pétrone
mondialement pour s'inspirer
puis dans la liste des pétrone de
podcasts les plus avec le plus de succès
sous écoute arrivée dans le top 500 top
5 était pas loin t il ya un site où est
ce que tu vois les pitchouns temps alice
pas loin avec tout les quais ce système
là pour 40 semaines
mais qu'est-ce qui aideront mon fanboy
pétrone spo demande avec beaucoup
d'argent fait que chaque 1er du mois
c'est comme ça ne sera cinq mille 5000
saint leu on va dire le 28 après quand
sa part si le premier jamais un peu en
beauté mais le stack en tabarnak c'est
du monde qui aime vraiment le show que
tripette trois pièces par moore qui une
fois sur deux ça passe de crédit dispose
mais c'est jamais le monde est riche les
plus jeunes et rudy salles en 3d qui
s'abonnent tchèque
les épisodes qui ont avoir peace des
abats ah oui mais je pense que ça donne
quand contre le paiement et fois je
pense
ils ont juste la caf poste ou peut-être
qu'ils reçoivent une notification
d'autres que moi tu as volé un groupe de
patrons aux notifications dit m
votre refus pour le mois d'avril plus
comme qui paye encore et encore le site
est passé de 505 4904 chaussée pour d
abord quand j'avais eu l'idée au début
où je voulais pas être patron je voulais
partir l'équivalent d'un comme un
netflix de podcasts que ce permis avec
la même formule que manger pour pas
trion toutes les portes 15 gratuit genre
dans un mot mais pour le premier morceau
son site ici
puis après ils étaient onze mais ne
gagne pas de gaz pas près son rap sont
100 g ans 100 piasses lo split selon les
vieux cons non j'en ai parlé une coupe
de personnes qui avait personne qui est
intéressé personne tout le monde faisait
en non ça marchera pas oublier comme un
pierre-luc de 3 bien il me disait au
lieu ça devrait dit pieper view comme un
luxe un fan de l'ugtg vous jamais simple
en apparence mais tu disais moi mais un
piper view un podcast personnes vont
payer pour un épisode
à moins d'avoir achevé un méthodes comme
le si je suis j'avais gad elmaleh et gad
elmaleh parler de vol de joe l'orge
pourrait vendre sommet
ch'ti pourquoi le monde paierait pour un
épisode puis moi ce que j'ai mais de
l'idée de s'abonner c'est que tu ta
bonne part souvent encouragé qui souvent
oubliés des abonnés pour s'abonner à me
la faire à chaque chaque mot cheveux
tabac pas prévu que j'ai payée ce sera
un mois le camp céline mois prochain
mais un peu un genre de campo midi le
réseau sur lequel podcast est un peu
seul point sauf aux autres je trouve
l'erreur qu'ils font c'est que le pad
cassé j'ai migré hors expo ce que nous
sommes on pas de casse en anglais j'ai
commencé à falun deuxième épisode la
semaine pour passer par dia se pose est
gratuit surtout si tu veux aller
chercher ben badi viewty view qui ddd
view a laissé la place à des écoutes en
france après comme les 120 millions des
cours d'allemand effectivement je peux
convaincu de la sq est ce que ça marche
cette façon de faire un nom sur ce j'ai
l'impression d'une vieille façon non ça
c'est vu que interdit comique est parti
ça y était assurée 6ème fait que c'est
lamentable qu'un sourire 6ème que
c'était un mois quand j'avais partie mon
patron je parlais 1 go qui était bien
proche de jeff fillion type des filion
avait participé qui doit relancer et du
podcast on est vraiment vraiment au
québec qui a lui lui a team the hills
faisait jeff ya juste russe à aller
chercher 700 abonnés il y avait 700
abonnés et dissout écoute fait je sens
un show par semaine jeff faisait 5
jours/semaine pizza fillion à québec
l'été 2006 lui talich est cherchée 700
personnes opta est allé chercher un
simple acte 2 5 les actes à la parole
mon but est d'être capable de faire le
salaire à temps passé la porte au début
on la donnait josiane qui a l'oeil ou de
l'album au complet
le pistard passe au début on y donnait
qui y avait des semaines que yves desmet
n'y avait personne
et quand il y avait des regards on donne
100 % de l'apport caprice tard une
couple de semaines qui avaient quasiment
rien fait qu'on y donne et france ont
ils donné 303 5 ans pour caillaud moins
ce qu après quand on s'est mis à rouler
lost est lui qui a fait 66 et trop le
tout la pente et quand il donne envie
mais là c'est drôle je le dis c'est au
lieu des lettres envoyées dans des
attaques est le même ça très cool
jeff fillion par exemple c'était
charrière s'abonner je pense était
peut-être 12 pièces sont réduits pierre
sous douze pièces ça faisait quand même
si quand tu calcules nombre de personnes
qui étaient abonnées ces revenants
vraiment vraiment m'est témoin je pense
encore c'est comme le l'idée de netflix
ya bien du monde qui ne faisaient pas et
finalement j'y repense c'est une bonne
idée mais l'autre vu que mon patron
marche bien j'ai pas au goût de vraiment
besoin c'est sûr que si je partais sauge
perdrais mes patrons ont fait que j'ai
moi c'est sûr il sacré aussi notre site
si ça crée une espèce de pot de
fraternité mais d'un espèce de proximité
avec avec les gentils noms mais on
essaie de répondre à nos commentaires
sur youtube mais des fois et il y en a
trop on peut pas toujours de répondre
sur paix tout en aimant qui paye on
prend vraiment le temps de leur répondre
et d'interagir avec 5 me mais un nom
mais peu de succès juste 5000 personnes
mais la brute et le monstre of de paix
jones et des commentaires pertinents par
ses stands disposés sur youtube
quelqu'un que tu écris ton épisode et de
la marne
peut-être 1 go ya tomber dessus quitte m
o est fixé par ce système mais quand tu
es pétrole font assaut cet épisode là
n'était pas bon train legault la fille a
même investi leur apprend la peine de
s'abonner payés qui salent la peau et
mais c'est pourquoi la marque c'était ça
va être
j'ai pas aimé sauve aussi pourquoi ça
veut pas dire qu'ils ont raison le très
souvent têtu fait approprié afin de
tenir au moins
je prends la peine d écouter aux autres
vu que cheikh s'est pas justin madame
qui me détestent m'insulter nous on a
fait de la potasse avec catherine dorion
là de temps en temps voire 2 2 fois par
semaine peut-être en une notification
sur youtube c'est quelqu'un qui fait un
nouveau commentaire sur le caucase
catherine dorion ben c'est genre est
acide grosse crise de comme il le voit
ces gens certes est un gars qui qui
marque catherine dorion sur youtube puis
que chaque vidéo est ce qu'on va parler
de faute c'est de loin le podcast qui
est le plus d'athlètes de loin c'est le
manque
ils n'ont pas écouté j'aime juste par
personne on peut écouter ce calade dans
tout se parler l'éventualité d'un
podcast gad elmaleh - est-ce que c'est
dans les discussions mais je le ferai
pour veille en parler moi je te connais
dessus le tu dois rencontrer je l'avais
rencontrée mais moi j avais ya à peu
près 3 4 ans je faisais un show en
france avait le frère à jérémy demay
benjamin il y avait un festival du mot à
l'époque midi l'armée s'était il voulait
un show en anglais il voulait un look
chic et moi et diesel gad elmaleh qui
quand il a fait l'offre pour ça - stèle
jean la fin j'ai dans mon gérant dit oui
si l'ebook 2d trop ce que je voulais pas
passez moi c'est arrivé souvent j'avais
des appels et on veut bouquet maintenant
louis siquet on veut jimmy car on veut
jim jeffries pitot et fige dit oui puis
finalement c'est moins 3 god brassard
avec jallet d'ici 1 à 2 des 3 qui
embarqueront embarqué qui est désert
puis gad elmaleh sont embarqués porsche
fait le show pire gad après moi moi je
fais un numéro dans le temps que j'avais
un enfant que je sais que j'avais mis ma
grena d'un verre de champagne pour faire
un gros lots de gagner en barque sur
scène après moi qui fais plein call back
sur mon enfant ceci comme un trip
et puis la part du temps quand je
faisais des chopin hautement liste
faisait sécher commencé comme
écoutez mes gardes chantait qui était
comme en train de magasiner mon numéro
c'est pour voir ces tags alors je
pourrais tu le fais ça je pourrais être
le fait est là il débarque sur scène
vient voir plein de manif est ce que ce
qui était connu en france le fait même
nom
il fait ce que tu joue souvent ici
longines faible le taux monte à barnak
site une vol je veux détruire savait
déjà ce moment là ce qui était déjà
connue qui fait que je pose est ce que
ta perception de la façon avec laquelle
il faisait les call back je l'avais vu
faire un numéro de martin petit a just
for laugh genre 220 avec moi n'importe
quoi mais je le regardais puis c'est
n'importe quel job qui faisait au lieu
de faire une bonne job faisait et qu'il
la regardait commun comme un gars de
sécurité magasin mais il y avait en plus
il y avait il un numéro que chez pas de
qui le volume je savais qu'il avait
volée parce c'est une gamine canicule en
france qui faisait genre dont 45 de gris
faisait vraiment chaud qui avait un
numéro sur le fait qu' il ya pas les
moyens de se payer un air clim dans sa
maison le chat comme tabarnak et gad
elmaleh gundy fois ce que j'ai tout fait
pour le retenir dans ma mère qui lui il
ya un fils avec la princesse de monaco
puis ils pas capables sapn a clairement
jeté comme la ch'ti d'enculé de qui
évoluent quatre pieds film est
finalement moi je le tchèque a pressés
pour voir s'il m'avait volé chemin qui
allait convoler parce que dans ton pays
où toute une frappe qui avait pleinement
nos autos et réécrit ce lustre instit
foulée puis finalement ils m'ont j'en
parlais pas personne par jeunes gens ils
m'ont pas volé peu après j'ai repensé et
un couple c'est drôle que six vols de
l'eau demande gens parlent pop art se
fait comme oscar est qu'il l'a pas fait
pas moins j'ai fait de forts comme je
commence à le dire
c'est pas devenu ma mission le métro ce
taux que j'avais je parlais de gad jupe
longue et cette histoire lors qu'ils
avaient assez de me voler ouais
le piper s'exclamant c'est un peu ce qui
très vite le bus détruits au québec
entre cueilli au québec mais ça c'est
vraiment tout pareil coop comics mais
surtout c'est que moi il ya vraiment eu
beaucoup de succès aux états unis
ben non on pensait que je faisais ce que
j'avais delà du gros qui je savais ce
qui compte que toi décidé de prendre ce
nom mais ce site est le bouc copie
comique un faisceau de pin coupe d'un
dieu sait qu il signe tout le temps
c'est à fait ben may chez pas son nom y
avait une rumeur que c'est un humoriste
français et maintenant l'entente en
france mais je n'exclus polluent l'eau
j'écoute et je passais le bac avec
michel barrette puis tu disais que tu
avais d échanger des e-mails à des
copies darfour je me suis enfoncé staff
and line mode il y avait du monde qui
avait 10 ans le monde doit faire le
métier en même temps tu copies comics et
toujours des français qui connaît là
camille comme beaucoup de talent mais le
lui tony mallet tellement de monde qui
coûte une écoute puis de t'en parle
tellement souvent qui a attaqué dans la
rue il prend le white probablement pire
au dessus mais là ça rien vraiment
changé en france il sort par exemple
j'ai hâte d'avoir passé moi j'en avais
parlé à netflix a 20 qui m'avait parlé
de tout - oui car je connais bien le
legault en charge des super show qui
sépare j'avais juste dit j'avais fait à
y faire attention parce que finalement
ça rien rien rien donné mais là j'ai vu
que tu son special sur son sort bientôt
il ya aucune pub auto c'est les seuls
peuples j'ai vu ses gardes surtout et
trois textes sais pas s'ils ont pas
poussé dans le sud - mais métier les le
monde sans aquiris l'auteur netflix ans
chris lye festival 5 je suis face dans
le monde mais ce point comme à ses fans
à lui je pense en crise mais les fans du
monstre qui respire tes livres et tu es
en france et pas vraiment comme des
geeks envie que ces trous nouveau métier
les camry geek ici c'est impossible
d'aimer quelqu'un de même par se fait
par l'acte et tu veux penser que la
personne sur scène tout écrit même s'ils
travaillent avec des writers je veux
même pas savoir que des writers
décevante fait stick c'est vrai après
4,1 que payer 180 instituts gap en avant
des writers vous je sais être con pour
faire un pas ce que tu en es mentor et
63 mais lui en plus avec l'argent qu'ils
ont cédé writers c'est correct bêtement
qui ont du reiter puis lui a les moyens
il y aurait pu dire il aurait pu dire at
il trouvé les maires writer des
etats-unis du canada du québec dirais je
te donne 100 1000 par année pour fêtes
et autres projets mettons stand up sur
l'écrit pour moi
qui sont matériels serait aussi bon au
moins ce serait original
c'est vraiment bizarre qui avait décidé
de prendre cette banque
j'avais seulement pour le thrill que moi
j'aurais voulu sadjo mi-mars et sa
mairie qui s'appelle dan harmon qui
parlent français lui lui a appris le
français sur des vidéos youtube lui ses
hôtes et ça c'est au niveau de quitter
apprendre une langue sur people
événement des studios du prix des cours
jean des coûts non non je regarde des
des sketches en français ce pigeard
garde l'attitude kg j'ai remarqué à qui
la face quand et du teil mots ça doit
vouloir dire 60 kg il parle bien ces
valeurs c'est qu'en français maintenant
il peut nous parler puis parle à peu
près la vitesse que je parle un accent
robotique lotis mais lui c'est un
excellent humoriste qui lui il quand gad
déménage à new york avait commencé à
écrire peau qui il m'avait dit que
garder foi maintenant lui envoyer ces jo
le garde des sceaux ses banques sur
l'âge est sûre je ne prends pas ça je le
pense il d'après vu que lui parle le
français y aller voir des vidéos youtube
qui voyait garde fall et jack ghana
visas non j'avais pas stade juillet cris
mais c'était comme le le thrill de c'est
comme un cigare
cornelio est cavalier un grain foulard
la tournée lui a valu des lieux de 1 mo
yan li na et magasins chez fo c'est un
foulard t'as pas besoin qu amélie 20-14
d'un flat call cas de faire à ses soeurs
des pauvres du monde qui volent des
foulards y en a d'autres ministres à des
carnets liu jeu pendant qu'on dit sur ce
sujet cornelius les rencontres il faut
parce que mme o'shea guitariste dans le
final four j'étais serein chose qui à
peine artistes dont connelly ou etc et
qui leur accorde tout bayt mal mais je
traite un homme qui le une fois par six
mois dans la vie quand les you like
disponibles signalent que tu sais pas
comment la parité gama délégué il m'a
fait ça à deux heures expliqué pas en
sortant du banc c'est quand même si je
donne aucune suite à ce montant il est
idéaliste et attend pas car ce n'était
pas encore le sucre vraiment un jean
marc parent qui vend des jarawa mois et
2 pire les deux m'ont dit non le
gouvernement belge yves andré
beaucoup d'appelés liban par être le
seul échange événements des pierres et
il peut plus parler publiquement quand
on va pimenter renonce à cjrc système il
était tellement cute j'avais écrit un
long e-mail
je vais dire bonjour monsieur deschamps
j'aimerais ça vous avant mon paquet au
début j exprime ses poings par 15 j'ai
expliqué savoir sous les gouttes pire
jument qui lui fait ailleurs
merci au revoir mais je ne décide plus
parler en public d'un préfet pibarot
bravo pourtant pas je sais pas c'est
quoi un podcast mais bravo pour la mort
fait bravo non pas un casque chèque au
mastic c'est drôle moi un message devant
d'échangés de droits votons pas gaspille
jean marc qui m'avait dit jean-marc et
comme 1 1 jean marc gibeau même plus
vieux que moi je le connais bien je
connais relativement bien jamais doivent
maintenant 50 2 53 mais y agit comme un
monsieur de 75 lui l'hiver maintenant du
monde octobre avril il est en fleurs ne
fait rien d'après ces gels go 7 juin
j'aimerais ça de façon pas de question
et j'aimerais sombre trouver une date
d'après marc je n'ai jamais fait après
mon dieu et dis j'aime pas sûr enfin des
entrevues j'en fais juste quand mon
équipe m'oblige là j'ai fait à 6 je me
mettrais pas que c'est ça j'ai alors
qu'alpha obligé son étude a même entrevu
par contre pezens août 1876
c'est surtout quelqu'un comme moi c'est
celui est établie c'est peut-être simple
quelqu'un qui veut aller tu es bien
paraître puisse encore quelqu'un qui a
jamais jamais fait maintenant deux de tv
ou de gros show télé sont stressés
passeront à ch'ti car à linselles le
profil type le son serait cinq minutes
en sentant jean-marc jean-marc faillite
jean-marc sa plantation écoute change
juste compter les anecdotes pis j'aime
tellement quand j'ai dit des grottes de
j'aime ce mélange et les généraux puis
d'avant la fin je trouve vraiment course
et quand ils font tout le temps la même
affaire en plus il raconte des anecdotes
de la vie qui est acquis c'est bien
intéressant et après le show ils font
ils mentent tout un fond ce qu'elle
trouve step latence montre l'autre qui
se trouve tout le temps tu là françois
pérusse
il y avait parlé travailler sous le choc
des vetos le cirque du soleil qui
écoutait les masters des beatles qu'il
ya en tandem et ont des chicanes entre
john peoples pilot c'était vraiment
intéressant
peu après après dans la gt comme c'était
trop long la beauté n'est ce pas c'est
avant une mentalité télé ou radio que ok
les boys on commence le show ça fini à
c'est ça la beauté n'a pas commencé et
puis quel fan mettons à un coquin
patrick huet le recevrez dessus oui
j'aimerais sauf patrick huard c'est ce
genre de ces jardins niveau le labrador
de personnes ça j'aimerais ça en plus
jess sa fille ben jessy sa fille à
travailler ou au bordel avant la
serveuse cependant les podcast
maintenant maintenant une coupe de monde
puis je vais demander à elle demande à
son peuple je demande à son père qui
lyon les deux dit oui ça jusque là
jamais besoin des fois c'est a vu que
j'ai pas lui-même avec la met en jeu sa
blonde me suis surtout étoffe de logique
rassemblant des ja du petit demanda pas
de celle fred mendy dit oui mais c'est
moi qui ai car je devrais faire tu peux
tu me donner les emails atom nom ça
serait plus simple entre ses sauces et
tandis que j'ai remarqué la relève sont
plus faciles à l'école et personne de la
relève qui sauterait pas sur
l'opportunité de
c'est plate que tout au long des fois
paraît en avoir il ya alex douville qu
on avait eu dans le temps puis avait pas
été bons parce que j ai trop trop ni
trop dans sa taille trop cérébral pilat
il disait support capable à être drôle
mais glisse pas drôle sur 100 que
j'avais fait mais fais ce que tu fais
sur scène mais lui quand il m'a parlé
des enfants ça devient à devenir
rapidement l'eau qui il y avait prêté
bon fait que l'or on voulait pas leur
âme n'est pas près j'y repense j'ai fait
on devrait le ramener puis j ai demandé
est fait un nom
je pars capable 6 1 je voyais trop
l'objet clos vu qu'on construit un
studio prenons pas de casse en anglais
des fois le monde de même qu'ils veulent
pas être devant le public niveau les
femmes sous écoute moi j'en donne place
d' un peu comme la version 1 2 sous
écoute mais avec je vais engager
quelqu'un qui va monter il faut aussi
les femmes sur youtube son offre il y en
a qui pensent au bar en laisse et c'est
là que j'ai vu que je vous écoute et est
devenu un gros show passe au début tout
moi c'est ça la beauté du parc à ce
pilot jarvis un patriote
c'était tout le temps des commentaires
sont positifs ou constructive qui moi
j'aime les deux ces objets d'art
si le meilleur show de l'histoire mais
je veux prochain estime avait ou en
chèque le gros tas de sable puis la star
ça a commencé il ya à peu près un an et
demi que je voyais en crise comme en
savoie plus de commentaires méchants sur
le fait que jeter
j'ai beau livre on maîtrisait plutôt que
j tchèque [ __ ] ce qu'ils te demandent
une seule occasion de but même mot
pendant ma dépression
jason qui fait mes réseaux sociaux lui
lui prenait souvent des extraits puis
mettez
on line pilots ça nous attirer banc du
mans mais je trouvais c'est souvent ça
attirait le mauvais monde c'est moi
j'aime ce jeu sous écoute a grandi
organiquement leurs tricks a été fait
que oui on dirait où j'aurais pu qu'être
la fable monte plus lever plus vite pas
avec la même femme née à mechiche
contact ça a été tu es c'est vraiment un
slot bild le mans la star ac j'ai
l'impression que tu comme le mont one
man show vient de sortir j en ai payé un
petit peu bas tv qui j'avais de la pub
gratis vu que dans le tages ta radio
puis à vos lieux d'un cachet il m'avait
donné de la rue en échange qui s'est
vraiment le podcast c'est bien qu'ils
restent là on y enlève un soir au club
soda cinq mois puis à 9 size le soldat
sur les neuf qui sont pas soldats et
régente 2000 billets au walkers mes
arguments tout soldat qui avec tes
seulement ennemis peu près 15 une pièce
de peu bas télé jeux soins je prends une
présence l'autre passe on se dit juste
montrer on choisit ont choisi le web
mais on pourrait pas de la télé qui même
j'avais eu l'idée une compagnie
j'obtiens la finlande traiter des
infopubs avait ça coûtera le scot 300
pièces on était dit je vais peut-être
acheté jean deux dames hier de genre une
fois par mois pour heures pour mettre
sous écoute qui jeudi des extraits selon
moi j'aimais l'idée de mon gérant les
mêmes pas passer c'est assis lui dit au
vote à venir
hugo c'est utile aux 100 km et invite à
son écoute mystères cachés dans tes
hommes c'est juste pour celles à des
placements qui convainc des billets je
mange me sens je me sens pas mal de
garder le pas très long mais je me sens
mal de le garder l'argent des billets on
se souvient fait qu'on leur donne
on leur donne santé à chaque qui est
quand même bon pour se déplacer en
région paca ce qu'on fait gratuit
on s'en parle après c'est juste des
bonnes critiques - vraiment mais la page
de triper hu était quand même super bowl
la piste est la presse qu'il marquait
show méchamment drôle qu'un 4 étoiles
state est la pire
la vie par ses voeux disait qu'il y
avait un but qu elles mêmes mots mais je
voulais même pas les voir la scène passe
parce que t'es débile des mauvaises
critiques ça ça prend un peu d'arbres
des bonnes critiques l'ôter comme date
les bretelles d'accès un génie et que je
voulais vivre bien d'autres avec le
voulait pas être un génie un arbre puis
je voulais bien ou ce que je suis mais
lol soir tout le monde médecins et à
cesena je regardais la semaine prochain
mais tout le monde m'a envoyé l'ailier
alors je voyais dans le lien qui met
tout le temps après pat groulx maman
wilm envoyant un email
pour quelque chose d'autre que je
commence à lire l'homme a mené une
chaude ch'ti 4 5 stations jones comme
tabarnak pas de grumeaux truc fait
qu'après j'ai fatah qui va les voir mais
jamais celle du devoir ou est-ce que
c'est comme une critique d'un show d'un
humoriste noircit un peu vulgaire mais
dans un langage des mots que je
comprends qu'ils aient vraiment fallu ça
faisait comme acheter stade intelligent
pour montre à quel point je peux
intelligent deux fois enfin luxe google
le mot quel jeu
un compliment merci moi j'étais content
mais c'était la raison que j'ai eu des
belles critiques c'était vraiment j'ai
l'impression que l'humour d'un dernières
années tim est on avec tes seins et
gatwick qui a été comme la soude et des
médias l'année passée avec blanc du
maupuy vraiment un message pitre si ton
humour est pas gentil et étonnement
d'étonnement classe taxes
on est en train de devenir de plus en
plus par leurs écrits correct avec les
gouttes avec les dreads qui ont pas
laissé faire à cause de ses cheveux
on dirait le monde comme d' arnaque on
n'a plus le droit de rien dire qu'ils
m'ont chose va tellement loin que le
monde sont juste content ça existe
encore et que j'ai même pas eu des
bonnes critiques à cause mon show et
bons jeux de bonnes critiques parce que
j'existe encore s'affiner au monde de
voix qui n'ont pas encore les loin drôle
quitter haïti mon show en plus c'est
souvent par soit on associe mont noir où
humour trash a déjà investi collomb a un
gros passé un petit moment noumonvi tout
sauf raciste ouzou femme à femme qui je
pense téléphone pour le le parti
beaucoup de monde qui aime le trash pis
ça veut pas dire que tu aimes le trash
que intérêt si ce mot jalil et joe grass
is mêlée joke raciale souvent ça me fait
rire
james white comme nerveux quand j'entre
un débutant ou sex-symbol ado c'est dire
le contraire de ce que tu penses
on fait ça tout le temps depuis toujours
pour une voix de colombes ont dit
exactement inverse de ce qu on pense
plus on rit meetic est pas tout premier
degré
[Rires]
la saison je pense que personne juste à
toi mais qui fait ça c'est la mildt est
beau je me lève le matin je teins peut
contacter un bon c'est un bon parent a
lyon on prend des questions nous inviter
sur pétulant de nos invités on prend des
questions de normes en pétrole
c'est vraiment un bon tremplin pour
cette question là en fait le sujet qu'on
a c'est à tyrosse - qui demande
un skieur ton processus créatif a changé
depuis la forge ring gabriel dans le
fond tu as toujours été reconnu pour son
humour noir excellent en passant que
thierry te dis mais est ce que tu es ce
que maintenant tu te restreint plus dans
ton écriture de port de port de renault
va vraiment pas même si c'est moins
après après mon procès ce gpo écrit
pendant un bon petit bout de temps puis
je fais tout le temps s'est aussitôt que
je veux un scandale parce que mon
premier réflexe et giteau qui vit un
scandale ou ont brusquement bas rhin à
tiges en neige en eut deux assez majeur
peu après des démunis lotis mais le
magic sur la petite cédrika
après ma job étudiant et demi les deux
fois j'écrivais pas de suite parce que
mon premier réflexe est enfin allé dans
chaque école et je fais de le montrer ce
que je fais pilot mon premier réflexe
d'écrire quelque chose qui crise montre
ou trash qu'après fait que j'écris passe
au pied après un coup que j'ai ma colère
a drop et là je deviens peut relever si
j'écris de couach comme je peux pas dire
si je vais me mettre dans ma vie ça me
prend tout le temps peu près une heure
avant de revenir comme j'étais qui
mangeait tout le temps penser les
premiers mots risque lui drame dans ta
vie qui devient tout le temps plus drôle
mouche devenu plus drôle quand ma mère
est morte samassa mots et des ah ah ah
ah et drôle parce que ty pour m'empêcher
pour t'empêcher de pleurer tuerie même
afin que ma blonde m'avait laissé un ma
blonde qui est devenue ma femme m'avait
laissé acheter deux fois le ch avait
senti que j'avais panier commun une
caserne humour qui loge elle est
ressentie avec le procès avec la
commission des droits de la personne que
chaque chaque fumeur que j'étais à 20
fait que ça a été une bonne enfant ça
été un terrible une menace a été de la
crise de marne et artistiquement ça a
été bon pour moi qui à sa mort la seule
affaire on dirait je pense plus à ce
temps mon numéro d'ouverture jean numéro
sur la commission des droits de la
personne
puis je nomme deux des membres de la
commission qui ont perdu leur job
à cause par les entrevues aussi le monde
qu aux autres si je fais bien attention
il y en a un qui a qu'à vous et encore
qui avait fourré un enfant avec lui je
le traite de pédophile loti au jamais
avouer que je dis qui a été accusée
perdre sa job à cause d'un scandale de
pédophilie
sas en affaires que j'aurais pas fait il
ya cinq ans mais là j'aurais dit les
deux pédales fort puis par semaine qu'on
parle d'enfants mélodrame asti s'ils
viennent par ces clans qui vont envoyer
des avocats je veux l'être et j'ai eu un
avocat qui m'ont dit un des amis de mme
paquette qui est à mon show la semaine
passée à tabac qu il dit je t'écoute et
puis je trouvais ça le fun part je
faisais à stephen t on donner à cette
conscience là quand même sexe pas légal
c'est devenu c'est devenu on dire est un
réflexe n'accorde c'est vraiment weird
look geste de réflexe là mais même
d'être au podcast mais pas temps d'en
marquer ce nom mais bon quand et shaun
white une ligne que tu te poses pas loin
mais c'est arrivé le show que j'ai fait
de la quand je parlais de la soirée est
encore jeune à gonaté que moi j'ai rien
qu'en de la soirée est encore jeune mais
guillem la sort est encore jeune puis je
voulais le bon pays qui veulent jeter
sous parlant une amie mais c'est
maintenant qu'elles se passent la soirée
tu es encore jeune j'ai enfin moussa
vient pas chercher mais scott palmer qui
les gones y entrer pour ce qu'ils font
c'est excellent mais moi ça vient pas me
chercher ça c'est ma vraie réponse mais
sous raids
yc antibes biens fonciers faucher
l'horaire fois que j'essayais de le
pomper mais j'ai tellement saoul je
maîtrisais fort car ce qui est en train
de faire puis les guenons peu plus
qu'eux mais non ils lancent famille
parce que j'avais je disais que j'avais
fait ce qui égale un stick sont pas
drôles j'avais dit que lyon avec le
talent qui ont ils devraient travailler
d'un block buster si lolita comme black
boys n'existe plus exactement
silvana match c'est le goût du
blockbuster mais sa marque et la souris
tard quand j'avais fait à ce succès le
peeling aupic - pas plus bas du monde
qui aime la soirée kim soo et cauterets
rejoint un peu le même monde une
patiente que moyen papa qui je te reçois
la forêt temps car j'aime surtout les
vannes de fillion et en quoi
c'est les antipodes la radio le groupe
autour de reims et catherine dorion éric
duhaime tout moment moi je veux je veux
savoir
la suite de l'histoire la dernière fois
que je t'ai vu c'était au podcast du go
maximum de ramener chez vous et moi
j'allais poser la question j'allais dire
inscrits était complètement choqué en
hypoglycémie
c'était complètement chauve j'avais pas
super vous avez pu entendre - puis pile
témoin le lendemain j'ai oublié mon
manteau parce que mon cas était sortie
de schorre de tabarnak j'ai pas mon
manteau bleu tu me regardes ce projet
avec à louis ii
non ça m'apprendra les retrouve dans
toutes parts comme à 5 heures comment je
me sentais mes valises c'est déjà faire
un
j'avais mis mon cadran avant d'y élire
ont donné tout repris des habitués on
dirait je le suis quand juristes de
l'échappée mois puis je les crissements
échappée puis lendemain matin je t'aide
botha 3h30 les capable de faire ça deux
marines bost d'être fonctionnelle est
encore chaud oui en algérie c'est fini
j'ai commencé à dégriser dans l'avion
c'est peut-être plus facile quand tu te
lèves pas là maintenant il ya des fans
de mac world avec alouite pauvres voyons
un peu moins un peu peur mais il y avait
un show en anglais un show en français
que qui c'est là que j'ai vu que ça me
prends moi j'ai mon nouveau chant en
français
non mais j'ai pas de nouveaux chants en
anglais qui le choc serait en anglais
chanté que tout le monde en salle avait
vu j'ai mis mon special gratuite au
village santec tout le monde l'avait vue
allemand était tellement content que
j'arrive pilotes
je faisais le même qui risque de chômage
de modifier les jo j'avais pas de
l'arabe il aurait pu tout juste
radiothon français ça marchera pas si je
pourrai mais pas les mêmes a fight -
c'est ça va falloir que je me juge
montrent un choix c'est est ce que toi
mettons le camp tu dis j'avais pas
l'arabe et le taux de succès ou au sein
est ce qu est ce que tu as l'impression
que le monde leur centre aussi non mais
chaque j'avais de l'air d'un humoriste
que ça fait 25 ans qu'il fait ce qui a
arrêté sa force et y était il y en eut
demandant même des bois qui sont bons en
crise mais le 2ème 3ème 4ème chaussée le
même calice le chaudron du rayon juste
modifie une coupe d'afrique
j'avais deux langues de ce boulot je
vais de l'un du gore était bondée années
90 une seule là tu fais qu'un métier
sport pour la fin du monde le monde et
autres banques comptent en méchante est
que c'est pas les réactions que j'ai
d'habitude vie que j'ai eu le lendemain
en france tout est ce que consciemment
maintenant 80 nouveaux shows comme tout
nouveau show au noiresque 8/10 faut que
j'y aille plus loin que j'aille ailleurs
faut changer mon style ou bien tu décris
comme tecra j'essaye tout le temps mais
change ma façon d'écrire au 5e prêt pour
être sûr que ça se ressemblent pas t
comme mes deux derniers shows j'avais
sorti s'expose peu près chien genre bac
à bac qui les deux choses sauf sam
beaucoup parce que j'étais mentalement
chez dans la même classe qui j'écrivais
de la même façon
tandis que la bourse était chaud lorsque
la première fois moi d'habitude j'essaye
jamais choqué j'écris mais afin que je
trouve ça choque ça choque qui mêlera
cholot mon but premier c'est est choqué
mon but premier n'était dit qu'est-ce
qu'elle sujet est tabou qu'est lequel
sujet ou boutiques ou fins vraiment en
sont les trans yes they must go qui même
à faire après
c'est mon numéro sa commission des
droits de la personne c'est de la
confrontation totale c'est moins qu'un
faux cul ou à commission chose que tiges
faisait amis début début début mai que
j'avais arrêté qui leur lâcheté je
compte insister sur mon but premier
c'est être choqué au début qui ça a
donné qui est drôle pareil je pensais
pas qu'elle est drôle au début je prends
juste le monde allait faire une
conférence
je voulais juste que le monde fasse en
partant face aux quais à sting est
encore debout très juste finalement le
show est plus drôle que je pensais
qu'ils allaient depuis lors ces gènes
commencé fait qu'à la fin de la tournée
il savait que je pense mon meilleur
choix mais c'était pas son mon but au
début c'était juste de montrer que tu
pas dessus parce que le monde comprenne
plus que temps que tati début le monde
passait vraiment quitté un trou de cul
pour vrai nom tandis que le cycle un
personnage ou que si c'est exagéré ou
que c'est un deuxième de grippe qui est
et ça c'est vraiment cause pas de soi
c'est mon nom de plus personnel mouse
qui est aussi un as fac je faisais
jamais sa cause du parcage et comment
ces enfants souvent traités moins 20 chf
et un job quand c'était juste a joke je
continuais mélodies fois après ma job
fait j'explique leur chrysler par joël
si cannes des épées et comme j'ai dans
le show dans une une fan numéro que
jeudi qu' il ya un monsieur en aide si
kim aussi ses petites affaires mais
après je m'en sers comme lié pour mon
numéro c'est transpire je fais un
passant ce pauvre l autre page fake
comme si le monsieur à mme soucy était
triple jeu de la mort dans le pubis
je le fais pas ça sauf le but de ce jeu
prend la peine de l'ex primat avant
j'allais juste fait à six demandes
comprennent l'accès au master des fautes
il ya tellement de monde qui comprennent
pas quand steve jobs fait que j'hésitais
un petit outil commun si des avants mais
ton sujet 1 histoire que je fais quelque
chose de cool pour quelqu'un mais que ça
mène à rien aux gags mon réflexe tout le
temps de l'enlever pis l'instar à cause
du podcast défaut je rajoute du vivant
dans la joke tu m'aurais que même si un
bot qui équipa drôle drôle mais qui
rajoute à au feeling du numéro je le
rajoute sauce chose que je faisais pas
ce que je pense et la confiance de
levitt montparnasse devant le public
la stage chez que si je veux un rire je
vais être capable d'aller le voir même
un gag mauvais style beaux chevaux
baragouiner sopi on va cesser ses
pratiques de vente publique d'achat
chaque de moyenne le seco dans le fond
dans ma tête ce point chaud du mot mais
quand je me fie mourir c'est souvent les
rires que j'ai lu dans le pas de danse
sont meilleurs que n'importe quel
régentant du doubs de que dans mes shows
à moins parce que c'est un gag c'est
tout le temps meilleurs quand tu viens
d'y penser que quand tu leur fait mille
fois puis l'autre sens a créé sont durs
et un robot qui parle
ses fans donc la ctu improvisé où ben
c'est ce qui plaît aussi sont là façon
j'ai créé cette eau chaude puis j'écris
depuis une couple d'années
j'écrivais tout le temps faim
puis après j'ai improvisé autour jusqu'à
temps que je trouve le bon gag de faim
il ya trois demis numéro que j'ai trouvé
les les fans sur scène il ya un ennemi
numéro stella soir de mai mais des
critiques et il improvisait quand même
soir l'objet trouvé la fin d'année
number sur l'eau j'avais trouvé l'une le
début de mon numéro
le début du show ce soir là pendant que
christine mans lens était sur scène
j'étais comme chris mon début mai semble
si c'est long avant que j'arrive dans un
grand rire à steve va dire ça en
rentrant qui se soucie pas de casque m'a
donné sa confiance parce que la part des
humoristes surtout une soit un soir de
mai dioscore changement 30 secondes
avant il ya des journalistes
avec guy a lepage d'un râle on ne
mettrait pas à improviser mais là on
dirait j'ai une confiance
du coup c'est que oui mais oui maison t6
peut être drôle
- là deux heures de temps savoir des
textes lois s'appliquent avec des textes
je me sens comme si je trichais le droit
mais c'est le trail du podcast aussi de
cela 6 pts aucune idée où ça va d'autres
on le fait on le sait aussi le à chaque
fois tu parle dans le vide
c'est tout le temps les limpers afin
témoin le style shoah
véronique et les fantasmes et rouge fm
qui était qu un mois qui faisait la
vieille version là que j'aime et ce que
j'aime de son jeu remplacé par un coût
d'occupation double impasse
ok mais mais mais ce que ce que j'aime
de show là c'est les boues qui ressemble
à un podcast puisque j'aime pas si les
boues qui ressemble à une radio moi
j'aime ça des discussions comme on l'a
moins c'est ce que j'aime tes qui j'aime
pas quand 5
aujourd'hui je vais vous parler de
baseball mais moi je veux qu'on parle de
baseband parce que ça donne quand même
mais je trouve tout le temps sur wii
la radio qui trouent 45 la chronique est
trop écrit son texte c'est 60 go souci
timide mais c'est loin c'est la pire
chose pour ceux d'al sadd et parme et on
sait que là où elle est le fait du bruit
c'est fait du bruit autres c'est la
radio mais c'est écrit
mais hier soir c'est qu'ils préparent et
puis quand même une partie des
discussions après ou mini bâtiment
abrite encore jeune sapphire souvent
même je trouve des fois les invités ou
l'électronique s'essayer bon je viens
les remonter mais mais mais ça permet dé
peut-être d'aller plus loin dans la
réflexion d'un texte potage de ces pour
moi il ya quelque chose de bon là dedans
mais il ya quelque chose de bon dans ce
procès une tpiy l'impression que aussi
c'est avec la montée du podcast que le
monde aime sur le plus naturellement
j'ai l'impression que
un couteau écoutez moi je sais ce que ça
fait un peu pour moi un couple à écouter
des podcasts à regarder des talk-shows
subi capable sentir maintenant le seul
que je suis capable encore écouter ce
genre tout le monde en parle parce que
c'est là un fils de vraies conversations
les longues entrevues comme un pas de
casse monter mes tripes mes tantes et
dans le temps le show à rousseau outils
aux states maintenant jimmy fallon
j'écoute sont mauvais c'est 5 ou lnd
sans que la personne ont raconté
l'histoire la répétition la mitis than
life a de même fait acter comme
sportivement le sticker c'est tom cruise
n'est plus penché dans vie que vous y
êtes aussi penchée dans vie que
maintenant le meilleur one man show sera
et comme s'expose le tarn c'est wild que
tout marche mais j'aime ça je vais bien
maintenant j'espérais quand il a parlé
moi ce que j'aime pas des galas juste
pour rire c'est le montage parce que
toutes les gagnants un peu moyens sont
coupés fait que les nombreux même s'ils
ne donnent pas de rires en canne se
rendre à cannes par ces jeux du monde
tout le temps
les sabres à ça prend des boues un peu
plus mollo un peu plus ferme
je leur avais conseillé puis c'est sûr
ils feront j'aime un piment comme ce que
j'avais dit au lieu d'avoir vos petits
sketches la tva stick personnes aiment
vos sketches fait surgir le gag one on
me ding à l'eau tiède et est toujours
une fiction de commun qu'ils ont bouclé
leur importe c'est tout le temps une
histoire invraisemblable plus loufoques
mais j'avais dit
un show réalité ou un documentaire de
moi je veux voir mes temps un numéro qui
plante j'aimerais savoir le brainstorm
autour de la table darcis qui eut l'idée
pinceau la garantie savate à part ça
arrive souvent des vieux pro tour de la
table
comment ça marche et après ça marche
fort calme sauf à un moment intéressant
je trouve pour le public de voir
quelqu'un se planter pourquoi que s'est
planté
après quand tu es quelqu'un faire un hit
le heat qui est encore plus parce que
pour l'instant c'est juste dit ça vous
rend ça prend des flops
c'est comme si chaque équipe de hockey
avec 92 victoires par année ouais un
moment donné ça prend un perdant c'est
ce que c'est ça que j'aime la danse ou
j'écoute quand j'écoute les humoristes
raconter leur histoire des chèques cd15
histoire de jetalliance bord le pire
personne qui est pichet pourquoi faire
comme c'est l'histoire du chemin et
yannick yannick de martino qui nous a
conté que tu y étais il était apprécié
et coutumes d'être au chaud l'italie
dans leur plein après eux pas été
capable de tenir son show fait que
julien comment marquer plat précieux il
insultait je sais pas qui a eu beau
petit éloge sinon sinon ce que nous on
est exposé jusqu'à ce qu'il fonde sur
écoute aussi c'est que si ton mois avant
de commencer que tu es si je connaissais
rien l'humour rapport à parce que tu
vois vraiment assis dans sa chaise
le show de cm2 d'entendre les artistes
les humoristes raconter leurs processus
raconter comment comment ça fonctionne
ce milieu de ce ça ça aide vraiment tout
le monde à comprendre et qui devrait
manquer beaucoup de comédies geek je
pense
il ya au québec à 28 maintenant d'un
début 2000 il y avait des fans du monde
n'y avait pas vraiment reconnaissants ça
a commencé avec en route vers mon
premier gala
moi je trouve que y eut surtout les
mettons saison 2-3 loterie qu'un truc en
tanins si favre on était 6 h
t as tout le temps à des banques comme
animatrice mais quand c'est vraiment
devenu comme sochaux qui c'est l'autre
et les premières fois mettons qu'on
voyait bellefeuille puis de devoir le
côté humain des humoristes qu'on avait
pu voir sa mère lise dion et on le côté
humain qu'on a d'elle c'est quand on
gagne un prof trophy pilote voit la
vraie personne pendant
notez qu'à encore là a dit qu est ce qu
a besoin c'est à l'index pittis pas
nécessairement sa perte elle qui
discutent mangent mais moi je suis
content pour le parc à ce mot au début
la première version c'est pour ça je
voulais pas que ça soit drôle je voulais
gens que le public québécois dans le
temps la façon je le voyais on était
comme c'est un obèse qui m'a dit tu
demande si le gâteau il est bon d'être
rayée du bon ton dessert la base liban
et c'est ce qui montre un gros tas
demandant s'ils mangent tout avec lui le
mur ouest où le mercato de la planète
pour lui c'est pas rigolo mais c'est
pour ça il faut que tu demandes à
quelqu'un de minces sur un bon dessert
qu'ici c'est un gars qui aime le script
gfr on va ôter sava une bonne façon
d'éduquer le monde que se pose pas parce
que ça éric c'est drôle tu sais pas
c'est c'est plus complexe au lancement
d'un show c'est mon but au début c'était
d'éduquer le manque finalement ça prenne
totalement une autre des rafles otg duc
0 personnes note
c'est difficile de dire du monde qui
sont dans la nature on parle puis on
essaie que ce soit sérieux dans sa
difficile c'est des gens qui
instinctivement vont chercher des gags
mais surtout - moi j ai je dit pas bien
avec mes émotions fait moi c'est mon
réflexe le huawei est moins chaud chaque
jean thomas jobin a perdu ses deux
parents l'année passée puis à l'année
d'avant pie xi ou jusqu'aux funérailles
à steve j'arrêtais pas de punch et tout
le monde en même temps c'est comme
ouvrir ce n'est ni ma blonde si je
passais des heures sa fade et photoshop
comique de grands voyages et entend de
l'homme a planté comme le vivre son
deuil china non t'as pas fait du bien
pour voir dans tout ce que tu dis est la
base qui est qui en mange
j'aime le dessin de martino il faisait
au québec le monde aime rire mayhem
papotant de l'humour comme le mot c'est
qu'ils aiment rire ceux qui
s'intéressent à lui mots comme forme
d'armes et on le tient mais ça départ le
maintenant ce que j'aime le fait que
plus de tonneins en avance et avait des
femmes du monde pilotes du monde
stéphane dumont se dire aux fans de muse
et ça c'est là que tu détestes le hip
hop capote sur le class écouter le jazz
les plus pauvres un thème tout la
musique ce pauvre ecc thème tout lui
montrer que leur fils que j'ai
maintenant il ya du monde qui font
mouche à moi j'aime l'absurde umoja il
absorbe un j'aime j'aime le trash chose
que moi ça fait 25 ans je fais ça au
début c'est un monde qui me voyaient
s'il ya même pas ça après il araminte
sean paul dumont mais la salanque même
pas ils font je l'avais encore de moi
j'aime pas le monde à mike ward mais ça
veut pas dire résultats et à yannick de
martino je vendrai de la mer chaud j'ai
vu de ma vie
j'aime ça que hong hong et c'est le sait
beaucoup aussi du fait de youtube qui
fait qu'on est de plus en plus bilingues
fecq se voit ce qui se passe aux etats
unis ce qui se passe en angleterre fait
des par tonne un peu un peu cheap un peu
anciens teint qui passait au québec il
ya 5 impasse plus attendre on voit
vraiment justement l'apparition de 10 de
plus grande diversité de ses lives
alentours des julien lacroix tpiy qui
ont toutes couleurs y en a pas beaucoup
qui il ya un mec se ressemblent mais
vraiment l'espèce de nouvelles vagues
énormément diversité dans un type
d'humour n'importe qui n'importe qui
peut trouver son compte
j'ai l'impression dans un style du mot
en partie le fait le fait qu'il ya plein
d'open lancaster sa fille que tu monde
en tant que j'ai commencé moi je jouais
beaucoup par j'anime des soirées du mont
mais la part du mans récit joué deux
fois par mois trois fois par mons et
c'est long à venir bon si tu mens 2 sur
5 rue flament antique l'instant ils
peuvent monter sur scène
dix fois par semaine actu vo de corée
gabon rapidement qui ça fait aussi vite
est obligé de monter sur scène tout le
temps ça fait que le monde qui aime pas
vraiment faire ça y abandonne nation dit
souvent à l'humour c'est payant mais
c'est c il faut être passionné par sinon
fait ça juste pour le cash toutes les
foudres adage pilot peu de mots clés
ciblés sopi le glaçage de style ce
portfolio tellement d'autres façons de
faire limite à limite je deviendrai
chronique en reste dans shoah radio
canwest et outils la stat et avec des
jeux pourrait approcher un style legault
qui a dit que la radio ça serait plus
facile d'alim péter lier le style parce
que c'est ça la beauté de mon succès je
pensais sans une femme qui disait ça
dans son documentaire milieu mais tes
cartes itunes vedette les cinq premières
minutes sont faciles d'après seul public
devient en ait tenté par un réel
surprend le monde s'est faite même si ma
styliste maïa ce monument reste préféré
ci s'y est pas drôle tu veux je saurai
toile thème du rire à pau avec très peu
de plantes et mein kampf est un vieux de
la vieille guillaume boudisseau je
trouve que le manque de respect qui
vient avec
pas de musiciens qui devient vieux puits
pas bon
le monde vont faire je m'attendais des
chanteurs team étant de carbone noter
que toutes les buttes boutons sur son
humour
mais c'est ça que j'aime de l'umons
sellal la méchanceté du nom déjà mais
inatteignable par an et il supporte fait
pavillon syrien qui fait plus d'en face
que même avec des fautes du matériel
rodez comme à date mon show va vraiment
me juin et soir que ça marche et surtout
de marketing j'ai fait un bond après
quand je parlais au monde
le monde c'est la seule fois que mon
verre extra cholot d'accueil out mettons
aussi des biens soit de lyon pas gréver
8 9 me soit le 6 mai aux autres ont
juste vu la solution équipe en crise et
sa part aussi est à consommer moins
j'avais acheté comme tu as accès
nombreux lots d'habitude c'est le délire
alors qu'il n'en existait pas la faute
du public et part seul voyage au début
était extrêmement worms et moins
blanches vacances tout inquiétés profumo
des bustiers qui était fatigué le jeu
m'a posé plein de questions pierre de
quad le fonds de réserve a eu la réponse
parce que maintenant qu'elle soit qui
marchent peuple qui cherche la raison se
trouve que la réponse souvent tic - le
défaut de mon show c'est que il commencé
moi j'ai tout le temps et met en humour
et disent tout le temps de disposer d'un
finir avec ta mère junkie rouvrir avec
ta deuxième meilleur tandis que moi ce
que j'aime faire c'est que je trouve
tout le temps avec mon maire numéro qui
m'ont deuxième numéro staut à mon
deuxième numéro
mais le numéro comme ceux qui la fin de
ton choses et de la marbrerie je fais ça
parce que celui-ci que j'avais entendu
un manuel en entrevue dire que il fermé
tout le temps que son stock le plus
faible parce que comme ce pagne est
restée comme tabarnak peut pas finir
là-dessus avec ton cerveau trouve des
affaires que ton numéro le plus faible
devient rapidement tu essaies de garanto
le tout londres - le mans mis deux
numéros les plus forts ces plumes et
deux numéros les plus forts que mon
numéro qui était de loin le plus faible
s'est rendu le numéro qui rentre le plus
fort parce que je l' ai tellement jaloux
tellement plus travaillé que les
optimistes
je travaille sur six sur scène que je
travaille le meti j'ai improvisé mais la
fin de dents mais lol défaut de vue que
j'ai monté le show de même mis numéro au
début il était raide pietà for pi genre
marqué dans le pc mon avant dernier
numéro il marchait tout le temps mal ou
jetés comme crès ok je vais mettre mon
numéro le plus fort là à créer ces
marshmallow aussi tic là je comprenais
pas pourquoi c'est l'autre soir j'ai
fait si je passais mon début vos justes
le jouer plus monde par son jeu tout le
temps en train de crier génois lafarge
fait joie de jouer malo qui danse de
nombreux lots je vois je vois comme
panier pas pauline a noté mais je veux
me donner plus d'énergie
depuis que j'ai fait à l'automne le bout
faible de mon job ce même pas le numéro
femmes mais c'était juste un porte le
numéro je restais debout faibles qu'ils
ont gelé fait deux fois que lon les deux
fois j'ai fait
or cri selon l'agent un vrai show très
affecté leur rodage c'est sylvain
buckley les choses le show prend forme
l'ava d'âge moi je crois pas qu'un show
y aura des six mois continuent à auradé
pilot vrai dessus lors les deux derniers
soirs je le rate deux vainqueurs la page
noire le 20 avril et deux dans les
sources trouvait que le show était pour
ce que c'est parfait mais je le sais que
ligne des enfants va falloir change
parce jobs parfaite aujourd'hui dans
deux semaines tighza ce refus sort
pendant six mois
s'il ya des sujets et comme maintenant
mon numéro ses transes il ya pas
d'autres maurice québécois ce moment
qu'un numéro se transmet si maintenant
il ya eu huit autres monuments humoriste
commence à faire des numéros là dessus
lors on aime à voir j'ai de la haine
d'un groupe fait du cliché mais que mon
numéro qui maintenant se faire original
mode à venir un peu quétaine
salut mon psy web pour sauter sa future
voie ça vient
c'est moi c'est la même c'est la pire la
pire chose à faire maintenant si tu veux
que le monde se rappelle de toit après
ta mort terme étant de l'amuser la
musique c'est encore bon c'est une bonne
toune aujourd'hui à moncton dans 20 ans
mais une bonne djoko aujourd'hui dans ça
va être un disque qu'on se trouve le
choc m'a le plus marquée de ma jeunesse
c'était eddie murphy de risque qui
risque assez bon juillet de la revue
l'année par cp neymar fillette en fumée
c'est tellement homophobe c'est vrai tu
regarde aujourd'hui petit comme peux pas
croire que j'étais client en deux pour
ça qu un tipi c'est la même chose c'est
aujourd'hui moi ce que je fais dans dix
ans trip taichung écouter sans fin la
partie mais sa vieille bobine
il paiera à figer dans le fond du film
outre la régie c'est moi même vous faire
constante évolution moment mont lachaux
je pense qu'il va le mieux vieillir que
j'ai capté c'est mon show en anglais la
raison qu ils valent mieux vieillit
sextet août des vieilles jo que ça
paraît plus que ceux des vieilles jobs
budget j'étais ce matin j'ai le numéro
d'un show là que j'ai écrit à peu près
quinze love shack en tabarnak j'enlève
la poussait un peu mais ça marche encore
fait que j'ai fait six ans un numéro que
j'écris des années 90 qui marche encore
l'eau ça veut dire dans 20 états il va
encore marcher même tandis que un numéro
que numéro dans le show serait sur le
hashtag me to be gilbert pire est que
l'eau c'est ça marche au bout maintenant
15 ans vont peut-être faire c'est quoi à
chaque mi-temps dont éric salvail
l'autre tout le monde c'est kim danoise
en personne dans sa réplique à jake des
geeks l'outil l'eau marche moins de
calories et c'est avec la conscience qui
s'éveille de la société en général il ya
des affaires qui qu'yves le 10 ans
passait très bien qui ment 1 sont juste
inacceptables c'est moi mais j'ai écrit
des contes pour enfants puis dans une
maison alors que c'était encore quant à
20 enfants a annoncé son sexe avec juste
du rouge du bleu le mans j'écrivais un
texte plus le petit gain échapper il y
aller chercher un ballon dans l'aube
c'est un gros ballon rose d'or avec des
ondées bio n'est qu'un dd des icônes
ac.b licorne ne supplée y avait deux
petites filles qui rien n'a rien ce
serait comme système glaçant et multi là
aujourd'hui me souhaiter aujourd'hui
mais dernièrement ne souhaite écrire par
une professeure giscon ses
particularités comme pourquoi est ce que
les petites filles rient est ce que
c'est parce que le ballon et rose j'ai
juste pour répondu mais parce que
c'était moi au moment où ce que je
l'écris c'était une réussite est quelque
chose qui se disait qu'il faisait là
maintenant
c'est plus vraiment le cas il ya plus de
couleurs liées au sexe excès sont
maintenant c'est moins recevable pour
les dans un livre pour enfants etc alors
quand je lis des popes mal intentionnés
les 6es l'époque n'avait rien il a testé
pas pour bourde il ya juste deux genres
de risques la bande à ma cherche le
trouble au toit moi je trouve que sur
certaines affaires
tu peux faire ok alors on va le modifier
mais quelque chose comme ça c'est pour
de vrai la saq choc as et écrivain email
à la personne qui l'a écrit ta vie est
trop facile que si ça c'est le gros
problème de ta journée au coeur d'un
livre il ya des petites filles qui rit
ballereau ces questions c'était pour
pourquoi pas la france comme un texte
pour l'apprentissage de la lecture puis
à la fin des questions pour voir si
l'enfant bien compris le texte la
question c'est pourquoi est ce que les
petites séries le elle la mairie a dit
c'est quoi la réponse à cette question
là est ce que c'est parce que le ballon
est rose je voyais elle je voyais
l'angle avec laquelle impose la voulait
pas vraiment savoir
la réponse est en légère puisqu'elle a
voulu que la musique achetée un [ __ ]
1 alors que tu disais elle répété que la
date
ok ça a été même réalité métier si mr
plaisir je comprends pas pourquoi j'ai
on a ce serait ça s'intitule c'est même
ce n'est pas d'accord avec ses cols de
l'oclctic d'associer tessa toujours ita
ceci c'est comme si genre tout d'un coup
ça tu avais jamais eu connaissance que
le bleu c'est lié aux femmes de quoi ça
peut changer de l'europe est d'accord
mais si l'enjeu est aussi de ceux par
qui choqua tout mène par cette envie
c'est pas tout le monde qui est jean
roch noter que pour bien des fausses tu
peux en vendre un personnage qui est
misogyne et puis c'est un personnage
misogyne dans une histoire ça peut
exister parce que l'auteur le sens où il
tient un personnage homophobes
c'est souvent je trouve la meilleure
manière de contrer l'homophobie c'est de
voir un homophobe à gex tu es si c'est
un ordre flagrant et mange d'amande
formation loin c'est son pote ça serait
différent si le personnage principal
c'est l'homophobe mes cours d'une
conversation yahia n'avait pas de carte
avec un patrick senécal qui l'a pas
longtemps ya une autre vie d'enfant pour
production et distribution par les
greffiers vdl métal gris a écrit un
conte d'aller lire à la ville de warwick
hills have you lie métissé une page dans
sa page puis après ça le violeur ça
finit vraiment mal pour lui il
s'effectue l'ipo suns à st georges
pilule qui lui demandait ce qu'ils
disaient que ça n'a pas de bon sens
remetez y ait quelqu'un que lui ce qui a
porté plainte à la police
c'est le pire c'est que l'article dans
le journal c'était son nom arrêté pour
production et distribution
je vais m'y ennuie avec les togolais y
avait des vidéos des petites filles si
tu prends pas le thème de l'article
lui-même je prends le temps de
l'arctique mais que tu pas un jugement
critique ton opinion de ce gala et de
son éditeur c'est que c'est dit ils
produisent la pornographie le petit
aussi de la manière c'était fait mais
toutes les petites c'était comme si il
disait c'est un auteur qui tarde à voir
le jour sa job si riche et attractive un
état cela il va en thaïlande films à
succès je suis autant je l'aï vu l'autre
fois en auto
il n'était pas en prison sinon ils
parlent gitane lumière le jargon qui y
était avec une fille elle est la fille
chauffer qui lui étaient deux en
championnat comme jean-françois l'icom
fixé longtemps
puis je voyais 4x quelqu'un qui mettant
quelque chose comme ça m'arrive loup est
ce que
ton ton pays d'appartenance le de
tourner le dos complètement mais je ne
pourrais pas rester maintenant à
montréal je pourrais pas rester au
québec je veux tu t'en vas en plus tu es
le mettons le pan des pédophiles lyon
biais t on pas le droit de voyager
méthyle canada d'un mois dans l'ouest le
canada parle pau orthez a vu d'abord
google c'est quoi la ville la moins
francophones une ville archi tu trouves
une ville de matons et 5000 habitants au
manitoba
personne d'autre tout petit parce que le
sinistre qui s'est quand même ces
villages de toile clabaut la veille du
prime la voix qui monte ont débarqué
chez bull baïkal oui je l'avais dit
quand j'étais sur scène tout les blancs
j'avais juste demandé j'avais fait c'est
que vous avez fait dans vos villes
respectives pour venez vous cacher à sa
thèse est vrai que les expatriés le
temps jamais les expats ans je me fais
ok je comprends qu au lycée ou route et
n'est pas légal et pas moins estimé mme
et il ya plein de pays que je comprends
je comprends l'europe comprend les
mettons mexico state juge l'asie je
comprends tout michael woods fait
arnaquer
vos vies westerwald henry fait mon
affaire que j'aime le moins du québec
je veux aller là la langue ce qui veut
tout le temps alors qu'un est enfin je
te comprends mais la faim qui m'ont
surpris le plus avec les huîtres c'est
la diversité raciale
moi je pensais salaires c'est inouï tpi
un peu de maintenant un amérindien qui
un peu de blanc
c'est le ratio or il ya plus de noirs la
bocca montréal a rajouté un petit
village en même temps c'est un petit
village puis par jour c'est des kings
qui me disait ce parce c'est oui mais il
m'a dit j'ai compté 70
aujourd'hui on achetait c'est comme si
moi j'avais dit ça je rêvais de la grèce
c'est d'arriver enfin et je les ai
comptés mais lorsqu'un 78 ans
j'ai même pas vu table aujourd'hui c'est
quoi qui amène le monde leur avaient
cessé en parallèle le gérant du bassin
black de toronto lui m'ont dit que c'est
surtout des africains
tout d abord sûr que sony faisons dans
leur tête c'est ça le canada sont dit il
sont dits en caisse ou je peux
travailler ou devant une bonne job et
kalou et au canada écrit sale à froid
mais pour eux autres montréal c'est
froid mais son fils d'un district
maurice après on tente un avion 30 look
d'aliant à miami c'est fou active piot
la même différence de température les
fous mon père m'a raconté motoneige
crise mise en oeuvre puis quand j'avais
trois heures on est allé m'ont pas pour
faire un fellowship à houston me
raconter la première fois que j'ai vu
une personne noire de ma vie parce qu'à
chaque 6 me et il y en avait pas assez
surtout pas surtout dans 90 il y en
avait paul le jeu tu arrives à
l'aéroport puis à l'aéroport que j'ai vu
la preuve le premier noir de ma vie que
j'ai dit ma main monsieur il dans les
bronzés fallu mamère m'explique que rudy
a pas juste des blancs depuis que je
sais c'est que si ce test est normal
qu'ils étaient pas bronzer le monsieur
wayne county mispolet que la diversité
les bacs plus maintenant maintenant
c'est justement de 1 à 3 ans il ya une
faillite téléphonique du cycle
secondaire elle est en chine a fait un
show du cirque en chine et qui laboure y
en a pas beaucoup la nano à se prendre
en photo la 10e peut pas s'asseoir dans
un parc sans que le monde il y avait un
qui installe en chine j'habite de parler
indigo vous avez pas de noirs pee wee il
m'avait dit faites vos valises montrer
des noix ample il m'avait emmené dans
une discothèque que c'était juste des
blacks et avait acheté les 10,2 des noms
qui j'avais fait bloquer les tuyaux
c'est la seule vague noire du chili
voyez une grosse nouvelle qui est sorti
cette semaine que je voulais te parler
parce que chaque fois qu'elle pointe est
un fan du des mémoriaux king qui sortent
le power - qui font un test à
saint-louis way qui a c'est sûr ça va
être facile mais je pense qu'on est
dégueulasse connais des gens nés chez
nous je voulais te ramener mélo en
compta qui pullulent au titre et qui
marche est un peu une res juste dix
boulettes de crise ça fait cheap amener
une boulette il va envelopper mais c'est
que moi le limpertsberg au début et
ajuste à new york - qui est liège en 3,4
s au new york puis un resto à elle et
qui - chaque fois j'allais new york
j'achetais gens je mangeais sur chaque
repos pendant quatre cinq jours après la
dernière fois j'étais tout le temps mais
moi j'allais aux ressources chose et il
te reste combien de la tanzanie en reste
12 parfait de -11 mais votre pain pâtes
ketchup qui fait le pas trop cuire parce
qu'ils voulaient pas me donner la prime
est métissé fragile si ce marché avec de
la viande hachée dans ton sac règlement
j'arrive au droit j'avais de landrin est
détraqué l'autre est-ce que vous avez de
ce que vous avez toile a déclaré j'ai
onze boulaire mais monsieur vous n'avez
pas le droit d'amener de l'avion n'est
ce pas de la viande qui loge à mener 1
cela n'a fait que passer vos amis ta
hellip j'avais fait dans le coin j'avais
dit ailleurs leur expliquer je vois tout
le temps à new york
ramenez sauge et de l'a9 où est ce que
vous pourriez mans chipé j'ai fait ce
que vous faites passer au canada mais
j'peux un resto qui clôt la madame a été
bien cool pas fait en vain
particulièrement venger son resto
disposons nous on a des distributeurs
mais il voudra pas que t'es pas un
retour mais tu peux essayer de donner
son nom avec mogi gougaud j'ai fait est
lucide un possible mythe hameau dicte
alim vendent comme on sait combien pour
une caisse c'est quoi le minimum que je
peux acheter su où ses troupes avec
l'oeil à faire moi même c'est un tu
prends en prendre je sens un parfait je
vends prendre trop qui après non j'ai
dit optimiste béat à orlando jeune
classe à orlando pierre dinon j'ai tout
le temps au lieu dit est ce que je
faisais est ce que ta venue les cheveux
ras lanouf où j'allais chercher à des
jeux d'eau n'est jamais non jamais khek
noi offert non mais bien à fort leurs
dates parfait le chalet falardeau avec
ma blonde
on les a ramenés à orlando pas plus on
les aura menés au québec un charlatan
s'est fait arrêter par je voulais pas à
cette époque là je n'avais j'avais trois
caisses de passer 1 40 par kas fait que
j'avais 120 boulettes et après quand je
n'avais plus le jab eric roux go qui
j'avais dit que tu manges pilot lui
momie en contact à quelqu'un qui pouvait
même shipping logis chipé à plattsburgh
experts eux aussi à la place d'youville
et chercher puis depuis quand ont sorti
la version 2 loïc shipu facture qui mon
premier god 9 au delà d'elle j écris
puis
j'ai eu un e-mail qui disait que
travaille plus la fait pas ce mot
probablement utilisé le même mot que je
veux prendre un autre distributeur puis
je vais prendre le nom de la madame de
l'épisode logo pour montrer que dwan
déclare sujet déclare mes gars ça va
sonner absurde mais le cheveu g120
boulette mais ces cd dvd ou burger tech
c'est pas fini un légume une viande fait
que j'ai le droit
c'est juste jeu de l'année la dengue qui
vont en moins d'enfants
la dernière fois que j'ai eu de la
vraiment fou c'est leur libye c'est que
c'est yvan tso juste dans l'instant qui
vendait bien au foot mais au début c'est
juste dans une coupe de resto ania qui
logent pas aller j'avais acheté je pense
dit cette saucisse qui un peu cuites par
ce faux qui m'écrit fait que la ville
avait mis dans un sac qui avec de la
glace dans mon auto qui l'a jamais
j'avais un les over dans mon avion
pilote quand j'ai fait les ovins les
lions dit monsieur vous avez pas le
droit avec ce que vous avez de l'eau qui
gît dinan spa de l'osce et de la glace
ne lui ont dit monsieur vous n'avez pas
le droit puis vu que je suis diabétique
j'ai fait non mais c'est pour me
médicaments bon médicament de lyon dit
vous avez des médicaments mais
maintenant ma glace est alors dans le
sac
meamedica menthe à l'eau la glace l'été
la glisse saucisses l'agglo j'espère
j'ai juste et pendant que les autres
parler j'ai commis monis linak et les
sauces c'est là ils sont venus bien
faire que vous avez des soucis à mesa sa
part atteint
la glace est en jeu sauf à l'isie ma
part j'aime pas ça moi je suivais eagan
depuis comme trois ans qui j'aime pas la
bouffe qui gagnent en général je te
jeter un carnivore dans l'âme mais je
veux pas la peine pour moi ça fait
classe tard tu peux manger la viande
sauf que le web ne serait pas votre
style
non mais l'hôtesse à saint louis je
pense la raison pour il faut saint-louis
passe cl oui c'est une ville de vrais
américains
c'est pas gentil ils font tout le temps
à new york que les médecines new york à
lille plein de vie gan labo tandis que
là ça marche le ça va marcher notre pays
avec la nouvelle version dans le test
est ce le monde disait qu'il voyait même
pas la différence est sûr que non je
veux bien w puis même qui accostent 1 du
parc en moins bon pied vraiment bien
fait parce que le bien de burgers quand
tu l'achètes comme ils vont au foot ils
super épée puis il ya un arrière-goût
que j'aime pas charles w je le sens pau
sont ainsi mettre la galette est plus
[Musique]
malin beckmann mus par quand j'ai vu ça
j'ai j'ai fait
as tu y vas me faire jouer en faire un
bistrot des big mac soins moi j'en
faisais dans le thème avec jean daydé
pas dit vg normand
j'en ai jamais fait avec des passes
robert groupe je pense que ce soit avec
une économie rendue à oui ça fait la
force et avec lui les j'avais pu cheval
mais si la même raison que toi c'est que
comme tu manges la viande sans mal
pendant qu'elle pointe vont endurer de
sincèrement tous les jours fait le
souhait je mange encore désolé mais je
pense mais tout est devenu de manger de
la viande navigon dirais moi du rhône au
saut je l'aurais sûrement pas fait si
j'avais pas eu vécu avec une personne
m'en étais activistes qui était vegan
ceci relève était juste par moi même
j'avais eu un déclic pour moi même
j'aurais fait progression elle me disait
je vais pas commencer à campsas juger
mais affective est le switch automatique
puis une fois toutes ses formes un peu
plus sur justement tuer l'industrie du
lait l'industrie bisou au mieux le tir
même même - votes reçus quand c'est au
début c'est chez moi je suis vraiment
aller par étapes film dauphins 15 ans je
mange plus de cochons ça fait vraiment
longtemps après après ce que les vaches
mais après a feinté quand je mangeais
des yeux pied du fromage le je me disais
si l'avant champ viande à l'honneur vie
que la vache à lait de la vache à viande
halal une vie correcte c'est juste son
dernier jour kirch un article à la vache
à lait à part sa vie et c'est qu'une
machine de brancher c'est à ton
attention très bon sens et puis même à
fatick comme les plaisirs techniquement
il y aurait un lot mais c'est que telle
ils tuent les plis poussé marc la
naissance et quand il évoque ses
démarches restent encore les vidéos les
vidéos de ce sont assez fréquentes
ballons roses mais tu es capable de
regarder ce genre de vidéos le manger
les autres piocheurs les gants à rien
sapin sur combo y avait il ya un des
créateurs même pas correctement des
premiers writer sur les simpson qui
s'appelait same time ans était dans le
temps un élément du cancer le minitère
souvent surround sound pour lui c'était
la première fois que j'entendais parler
un big n avait pas de lendemain un style
où il doit annoncer son arrivée gamestop
des instituts weirdo astique images
thijs abidjan alain quitté dimanche la
luzerne à quatre fois par jour si c'est
pour beaucoup comme un corps warwick
mais moi cet agent de beauf l'on sait
qu'avec le monde font ça mais moi j'aime
pas ça je trouve ça dégueulasse qui lui
je l'entendais parler qui y possède un
première année que je mangeais pas de
cochon qui disait que lui sa transition
avait été 2010
j'ai arrêté de manger le cachons que je
me sentais mal pillot digue est une
pente que souvent tout le temps 30 au
sitar est une enfant tu ne trouves pas
ça cool manger aux cochons qu'ils sont
intelligents
après tu vas pensée pour faire à la
vache au site intelligent peu près 3 fin
la poule akon mais parce qu'elle est
conne cas mérite pas d'écho à 6 m
mon cousin trisomique il a le droit
d'exister hôtes un style qui fait qu'il
a appris après puis après cette loi a
créé genre est élu il à paul le talent
est séparé depuis un moment donné quand
tu deviens begun to put être questionné
pente hot fuzz banques et là je me sens
plus mal
un tri je me sens plus coupable je
m'étais posté je sentais tout le temps
coupant tout a grandi sur une ferme
moi j'ai grandi sur une ferme quand
j'étais petit mon père quand je devenu
big angels avec tous les domaines et
vegan parce que moi je nommais au début
on avait des vaches à des vaches à
viande puis j'ai nommé parce personne
n'avait dit nome la tâche propos est il
mort et moi génomique chaque fois manger
de la viande mon frère me disait le nom
de l'animal qu'on mange
pisté pas sûrement le vrai nom le meti
m'attend si on avait une vache qui
s'appelait sophie qui est à mon père
l'avait vendu la veille son manger un
steak était comme petit bond assez bon
c'est sophie bloch plaire
les filles j'avais arrêté il m'avait
fait 100 m emmener quand je mangeais du
veau et du bon kilo il m'avait dit c'est
le petit le petit veau que tu avais pas
normal celui qu'on mange je pleure mg
plus jamais de manger de vaud jusqu'à
temps que j'aille mettons vin est un
objectif commun 15 ans chance à manger
de nouveau 1 2 ans a manqué manger
aucune viande métier je manger du poulet
dans ma tête du poulet viande vu que
j'ai il n'y avait pas de nom puis après
quand tu devenu vegan mon père m'a
rappelé j'avais complètement bios
je me rappelais que je mangeais pas de
je mangeais pas de vous ouais mais je me
rappelle pas de cette traumatisme
l'autre mon frère m'a fait vivre
c'est comme un chien m'a même temps
c'est vrai ça allait se finir
ce fut un autre dans le fond c'est un
manège faisait tout le monde en parle
c'était dany turcotte savait être mais
il m'a demandé pourquoi je mangeais pas
bien j'avais un peu raconté sow qui
j'avais dit je me sens mal manger
quelque chose qu'avait dire a expliqué
me dis pas qu'une vache se dit un jour
je vais être à noter là il faut pas
exagérer mais je me sens mal manger
quelque chose qui a un frère qui nous
sert pillé triche que du bonheur un
puits de la tristesse puis c'est le lay
a dit wang somme c'est un peu
schizophrène penser d'eux mêmes notent
un peu oui j'ai fait moi mais ce
populeux oui que de penser que parce
tout la gère c'est dans un petit pas
quand ces réformes que ça jamais été
visant leur exode tafer lyon 1-1 s'il
avait vu tu leur est flatté par fethi
ben bella des gros yeux pilote amange
fait moche pitt will de de penser à soi
mais tout est encore plus 8 2 po et
penser que la passe toutes ces vidéos ne
seraient pas grandies de faire pareil
mais mémorable en et végétarienne depuis
un mille 1 puis fait que je serai je
m'enligne pour être végétarien qui est
ni oui et puis qui sait à force de tes
mettons arrête de manger de la viande
fait le spécial de troupes après tu fais
à mes yeux un kristofic
ce pose trop de questions je me sentais
tout le temps mal ce qui est je suis pas
une bonne façon de vivre non moins c'est
ce que j'aime mieux à être heureux puis
qui d'autre c'est juste compliqué quand
charlotte le mettez vous savez le triste
c'est mais pour ce pas la fin du monde
il ya des pays qui marche règne cela
m'aide pour avoir de l'eau brune 1 - ça
spoile jane dans un resto que la seule
chose qui vendent ces des frites c'est
bon mais john joseph
non c'est ainsi un gay qui fait dieu et
d iron man des trucs comme ça mais c'est
aussi c'est quoi le nom de son band bien
plus de 100 bénévoles la chanteur de
benno record à new york puis qui dit que
vu que vue des concours de tous ces
faits cet abîme coupe de fours at il
ajouté comme lui tu allais assure joe
rogan puis c'est un des rares podcast
c'est lui qui parle il parle il parle il
parle il parle peu il raconte lui dis
moi je suis viguen mais je me définis
pas comme un beagle et je joue avoir
rien à avoir avec l'espèce de culture
viguen ou l'etac vie parce que lui dis
moi c'est juste pour les animaux je
marque alice de ma santé nécessairement
par parme habitations this post chevaux
je fais pas dit aux gars je fais pas le
juste pas tuer des animaux c'est juste
pas de nourrir et aux animaux pillées
vraiment hittistes instinct statoil pied
je pensais à ça quand tu parlais tantôt
de veegaete
toi t'as vu pour la première fois avec
la crise je peux à être comme ceci juste
être comme ceux s'arranger d'en parler
tout le temps mais ça l'a fait je pense
le monde pense que les big n en parle
tout le temps parce que c'est compliqué
au resto voilà c'est maintenant si tu
fais the highest viggen
ils vont dire oui pas prêt et à la même
pièce de la mer n'a lofo chirurgie j'ai
fait la gaffe de paul spécifie 22 faux
mais j'allais au resto de à côté du club
sont dotés les accords le restaurant a
lepage qui je voulais prendre un verre
ça me tentait pas d'aller dans un bar
avec du monde fait que j'ai fait qu'ils
sont allés prendre un verre au resto on
arrive que le serveur
il savait que je rêve ils gagnent puis
au fait que tu manges et des finances
juge s'en va ailleurs lee telle affaire
on le fait vers son véhicule ces malades
et que j'ai fait à qui je dois le
prendre
les meules à mener mais c'était sur une
salade crémeuse à claude l'homme j'ai
pris une bouchée au début puis j'ai vu
comme là j'ai fait à tabarnak
ah oui j'y pense j'ai pas pensé il y
pose est est ce qu'il n'ya pas de
crémiers pas et c'est pour ça qu'on a de
la gueule parce que et tout le temps que
j'ai fait un gain revient des produits
laitiers quelquefois n'y a pas de
produits laitiers au kenya ou sur toi à
moi c'est vraiment une sauce à la crème
aux rockets - le québec ces méfaits
qu'il faut que tu le dises 28 fois c'est
sexe pour ça qu'on a demandé gosso mais
moi ce que j'ai ce que j'ai réalisé dans
des tons 15 juillet dans des super entre
amis ou quoi que ce soit pire
le véganisme vient sur le sujet mais
c'est pas moins que là maintenant c'est
ça la fabia mener c'est qu'ils
changeraient de parler plus je me dirige
tenteront encore parlé de dégâts ni la
justice pas moins qui a amené le sujet
this pas parce que mon assiette était
pas la même que celle de tout le monde
mais j'ai pas rien dit mais ça vient sur
le sujet parce que tu confronte un peu
les gens sur leurs ascendants et puis
aussi le monde je pense la raison que le
monde n'aime pas souvent les big c qui
sentent coupables c'est parce que
mettons si si personne n'en parle jamais
ce sens pas mal de manger un steak par
suspense pour ce qu'ils pensent pas
comme ça n'existait pas comme ce com
mettons les sans abri voire lingots
dormir dans rude stade axa pas de sens
mais là ce moment il ya des sans abri et
ce type qui ont un piano par sport c'est
sûr quand on y pense pas à en tirer sont
un petit fait que je pense c'est ça
aussi qu'on m'en parle et de vega nice
le monde font à un à un ses vrais stis
pas cool après le 10e temps moi je
serais pas capable je me trouve la
viande
ouais moi aussi j'étais c'est rare que
ben pauvres et j'ai remarqué il ya deux
genres de viguen garneau qui aime pas le
goût de la viande qui pour eux c'est
plus facile
les filles surtout soins du féminin ma
blonde et est devenue végétarienne par
celle réalisée car à manger quasiment
pas de viande à l'époque mettant des
années 90 quant à manger aller mais
perso avec c'est facile en crise devenir
végétarien quand la viande les oeufs
quand tu aimes le goût de la viande
l'autre c'est un peu tafti mais tout est
faisable tactique en dessous de sa
quelqu'un qui est comme moi je pourrais
pas où je pourrai pas et je suis trop
souvent sa route qui rythme jusqu'à 200
euros par année souvent un petit village
qui savent même pas si quoi être
vigoureusement montr poste 1 oignon
si je réussis fait qu si j'ai réussi de
n'importe qui pourrait mais quand cela
le monde se sent coupable pileux ils
font crécy est en train de me juger mais
je pense train de juger les jeunes
jusque 6 si tu veux tu peux mais c'était
pas obligé de vous lancer seul
c'est l'autre question après midi puis
je suis devenu triple jeu devenu
vraiment au but quand je suis devenu v
gueule parce que tu es j'arrive nerfs
d'un resto wild qu'il y avait un option
piste est tout le temps d union
française des fruits - c'est son outil
d'aidé des peco jamais pas parole vegas
qui l'attend pour l'image des vitrines
61 go un peu un peu plus vieux qui avait
de la junte jusqu'à tendu la vienne
vigueur j'ai pas mieux qu'un coup de fil
au début et je me dis ça crie ça serait
drôle si je deviens part je regardais
des shows genre my life ne lisent les
eaux ainsi je deviens vraiment au miles
à cause de la cause du véganisme ya de
quoi de drôles de dames et messieurs que
ça prend quelqu'un de la vie de sosie
ils mangent aucun les hoquets de la bête
d'avoir vu sur un show avec un anglais
de brighton en voit souvent des as face
aux deux autres les autres exemples ici
même au boîtier surtout honda et de
penser que je vis à et les versements
suivants débit end et ont fait l affaire
à hélices tu peux envoyer sur arte et
france 2 alix démarré à les connaître au
ghana
mes cheveux s'il pense à vue que
publiera pas la fabriquer il faut
souvent l'étape à me wade qui lui lui
par exemple j'aime j'aime sa mentalité
la tude dimanche ils mangent plus aucune
violence sauf l'avion quoi là dedans
simon leblanc qui est un peu d'eux-mêmes
sauf lui ce pas de la viande qui tu me
manque juste des animaux que il ya déjà
tué cet animal là pour se rappeler passé
dans le fond le problème c'est que si tu
réalises box est un être vivant c'est
vraiment seul problème par site est
conscient que stava shove river mais
pitt aurait été capable latulippe
d'honoraires avec mangent les petits
mouchoirs est pas capable un suivi une
vache je serais incapable de mener de
jeudi visible pour un style de danse
c'est quoi ce serait incapable je serais
incapable fait qu'un pied simon laplace
ce qui dit fête lui qui a déjà tué une
polka qui mange du poulet
il ya déjà des jeux tu un lapin fait que
manger du lapin mais je me rappelle plus
si il n'ya jamais trucs cochons fait
qu'ils mangent pas de cochon jamais tué
de vache fait qu'ils mangent pas tous
take mais il va manger et que tu peux
savoir qu'est ce que tu es
s'il marche si tu veux manger un brin on
va appeler la police
joe rogan y avait déjà dit richard
castor vegan avait déjà dit qu'ils
sentaient joe rogan sentait qu'il y
avait plus en commun que les vegan que
le monde qui mangent leur viande
encaisse pris au sens où ils mangent
italienne que lui tu es il refusait
complètement le l'industrie de la viande
est complètement tout seul c'est juste
parce que ils respectaient trop l'animal
comme tel puis je pensais à penser à
évoluer ce qui est excessif et ceux qui
collectent shologan déjà pensé évolué au
fil d'un petit n'est pas fermé d'esprit
par rapport à rien dans ses mandants
dans le temps je m'en rappelle même
salle est vraiment un des psaumes ma
part je me rappelle d'un login faisait
du stand d'objets des années 90 des
de même je trouvais ça ordinaire pas
presté guillon magna qui me l'avait fait
écouter jean mettons mi-2000 piste est
déjà je le trouvais meilleur pilote
depuis c'est son parc à sa star c'est
quasiment lui dans la conversation avec
du monde que tu de montbrillant fatiha
prend tellement d'affaires qui trouve sa
lettre vraiment pour son humour et non
son dernier special je pense à cette
laiterie girl way était vraiment bon
bougeait pas capoter à stylet mais sont
moins en moins j'ai trouvé le thème
était bon mais je trouvais que ce délai
vous et andré qui dit il cricri sains et
saufs mais c'est un illettré mans
l'alpha moi je l'avais vu une fois
quantité venant montréal sont fans boys
à l'époque c'était avant sont pas cassés
que 10 des gens de gabat aussi fan du fc
tout le monde et des chandails ta parle
de piloter un manet la veggie pride à
parme en il y avait une fille à la
vecquerie est quoi
c'était un clarté d'aptitude facile à
laver je sauvegarde et puis avait dit
chad ap stupide ailleurs le yoyo faite
ait pas cool parler de mamane femmes qui
les y avait lancé copies et s'étaient
taux d igor qui font du mm x emprunt ou
tic dans leurs têtes sont capables
d'abattre le stade relevant tout dgac
avait pas de lui nous estimons l'ample
ya de l'air du golfe en prison y arrive
à quelques pas puis c'est lui qui
rendent la place exactement mais
peut-être capital et là c'était il y
avait senti ce genre de rapport le qui
essayait d'être reçus d un peu un propos
un peu mémoire quand je rencontre l'âme
en bouche très jobs jobs jobs fille est
super sérieux ça moi je pense moi je les
déstabiliser qui lui m'a déstabilisé
c'est la deuxième fois que je le
rencontrais la première fois le haut
comme l'histoire moi il m'avait écrit
sur
[Musique]
sur twitter je vais envoyer quelque
chose en 10ème sur twitter là il m'avait
écrit à ce titre j'aimerais savoir à mon
pote tu gagnes c'est quand la prochaine
fois tu viens et les six mois je vois
jamais allé je me sens comme amateur
j'ai regardé mon horaire que j'ai fait
et je suis là du 6 au 8 j'ai pas eu
triche peu avec claude ce sujet mais
j'ai fait choix du 6 au 8 mars matin le
géant voisin kg il me répond points à
clash fait asti partage beaucoup car je
me suis booké des billets d'avion chemin
sous louer une maison labo dallas et les
voir mon seul ami qui la loterie je suis
passé la semaine au pyla niro guen qui à
l'époque je voulais pas leader s'est
caché commencé grâce à quelqu'un verse
tic21 aussi je le sais tu es maintenant
quelqu'un qui me fait la demande que je
veux avant ça se peut que ça prenne des
fois un mossi moins une est dispo à mon
gars à tous et je vais te remonter haut
de la liste
je vous la fait à lui à tout le monde
mais je me disais je vais aller
témoigner quand je vois elie la plage à
mike comrie store il ya comme une
terrasse salle à l'ambiance du festival
du mot passe c'est juste des humoristes
tout le monde se tait j'ai l'impression
ou un robinet tout le temps là seulement
des lots qui est quoi que j'aime de dudu
comme laissera tout sens comme state aux
seconds avec moche marc abel les
premières fois j elle est jetée comme le
petit cul de 6e année qui allait dans
les parties de seconde en au secondaire
un cas comme le gop on coule pas prêt d
année en année que ty par des contacts
pas des trucs chanter qu'à aucun moment
un statut le pilote thk au christ le
champ du commun secondaires trop qui
aussitôt que mettons un développeur la
rive se réalise onewest en seconde à
retrouve lui et à lui
le monde qui me lie celle qu il y avait
une note les analystes de moelle avec
chapelle vient de rentrer dans le lard
qui je me jetais tout le temps le pilote
ayant amené mon chat mindy fait écrit ça
rogen rogaine il est seul show est sur
scène il va débarquer vrai vous y parlez
pour qui tu vois que tu es tu as et les
jets fatras qui parfait je voyais aller
pilot c'est le jeu mais étaient en cours
deux domaines de ma vie et en parle à
quelqu'un d'autre qui l'on n'avait pas
l'effectif subit pas pire ça siam quand
bettiche jeu correct ça serve à jeun
meetic d'au moins 3 ans dans le corps je
suis à l'aise actuellement mais agen à
agen si j'avais de la nano cible donc je
suis arrivé clust com
ahidjo piliers comme les pieds très
froid puis je fais à quoi le fait
qu'elle en fait je parle mercredi aurait
sûrement pas la cible
lorsque vous parlez à côté des toilettes
je commence un cycle et j'entends rogan
faire mais il parlait pas de moins mais
mouche face ils parlaient de monter
comme apte à bas la junte en sortant
robin qui comme six lots après je
l'entendis t il jusqu'à pape faye rire
quand la salle c'est juste des noms en
6e portes claquent dans la salle
personne ne rit plus calmes à la
chapelle vieille par les tonnes milles
par les gens de nom mais il parlait de
gens là ces soins jamie foxx ou encore
celle ci me parler de la conversation
avancée crise du nord après le carton et
que j'avais faite a créé je pense je
pense pour de vrai sur le coup j'ai fait
j'avais tellement faim canaccord inc
sur j'aime fauqué méchant j'irai plus
générales sont prévues avec rogen qui
ont aussi joué de la façon je me suis
fait bouquet sur rogen mois à chaque
fois que je faisais à chaque fois que
j'ai fait un road trip 20 dernières
années
montréal floride robin ça donnait tout
le temps qu'ils parlaient de moins
pendant que j'ai dans mon chat avec lui
n'ont même pas c'est que le monde des
techs et passez moi j'exécute jamais la
belgique est facturée au taux plein de
textos
la première fois j'avais reçues
j'écoutais plein de potes 15 kg je
recevais plein de textes choisis christ
30 ans du héros guen a parlé de tout
cela sans char la deuxième fois il y en
avait qui en avait parlé jeu tant
qu'alan charles direction floride et
l'eau cette fois ci j'étais en train de
tracter mes enfants dans mon monteur
bosse pour descendre en floride qui je
reçois un appel de planter risque pas de
casse avec mon anglais et comme crise on
vient de se fa bouquet à john logan j'y
fais ta fac à chaque fois que d'à côté
si je veux des bonnes affaires
ces malades se désinstaller aller retour
elle et moi c'était juste mais on ya
l'aide des jo pour eux on fait une coupe
d'autres pas de casse mr d'ipad cas ce
genre cool à faire mais qui n'étaient
pas des managers puis rogen s'est
rajouté fait que j'étais vraiment
content puis la fa qui était wild ou que
j'ai senti qui est un peu le mans
l'alpha j'arrive avec un pantalon ce
pilote et par tim moss fait longtemps je
fais de l'humour pintal ans fait juste
une coupe d'années quitte il sanglote
parc expo allemand n'a parquet que
c'était tellement fiable lui estime
qu'il vaut faire joe rogan tabarnak un
gode park ex fait joe rogan tout le
monde tripet
on arrive kg en différé mais no mercy
est là il fait arrête avec ton ami peut
rester dans le green room nous autres on
va aller faire le podcast loge fait il
peur ça me ressemble
vous avez bouquet les deux non non non
non c'est juste là on avait déjà annoncé
sur twitter que ça l'est moins depuis
lui on avait des clones est rentré dans
lost et comme d'hab
n'achetez pas ben pilot jeu savant de
commencer leurs organes fait et je suis
vraiment désolé ptom pauvre elle est
désolée du malentendu c'est juste comme
chamakh et ses poches
il ya fait tu veux tu veux tu vraiment
qu'il fasse que j'ai fait ce serait cool
pour vrai la part celui lui il ya de la
crise commentaires la toute jeune homme
qui va se faire écoeurer avec ça ok
parle 19 et l'australie le chercher mais
j'ai fait tabarnak ça a été un oui par
moov juste avant de rentrer à nantes
comme lui c'est qu'il n'ya pas parler
tant qu'il a le tennis m'a dit mais je
comprenais rogaine que tim robbins un
coq rouge fait aucune recherche mais pas
de casse mais lui quand même voir des
recherches et qui connaissait assez bien
mon qu ils connaissent assez bien ma vie
mais il connaissait facal son pantalon
avec le utah comme je suis désolé je le
connais pas je n'ai jamais vu ce thème
pourtant à voir memish tech saupin
thalassa prestige pour est tué quelqu'un
il m'aidera cacher le cas vous avez des
styles et paca sont tellement différents
que ya eu un genre de
pas de clash le métier lui justement
même si tu me reste en podcast est ultra
sérieux parler de trucs un peu plus
intellectuels y ait pas ta légaliste
d'autres sujets puis le cema l'appareil
que soient les leurs puissants une
vitrine incroyable
- salut vraiment affecté mon jeu j'ai un
super chaude en anglais qui que j'ai mis
sur youtube mais qui titre sur la maison
de prime aux états que j'ai vu l'impact
des erreurs c'est que je tally de m sans
view par jour à 38 me ce soir c'était
des villes goggins l'hôpital à son show
qui est un comme un ancien navy seal qui
fait du d'encouragement fitness
d'ultramarathon lui disait que avant
d'aller à horgen y avait soixante mille
abonnés sur instagram père sur pablo gun
était au dessus de 800 milles comme cela
la semaine après se sont installés g
pilotes comme ses affaires après ce
seuil est à la bourgogne se fait bouquet
pour toutes les autres
mais ce qui est avec logan pu faire plus
que tu fais un humour québec mais au
stick pro du monde qui élèvent des
niveaux incroyablement c'est devenu lui
le nouveau 1
le nouveau maire de lille si c'est lui
le gros monsieur passe au début moi je
le décrirais tu le temps passé comme le
johnny carson dit en demandant mais
c'est vraiment le haut prodigue au
rythme où ça m'avait j'avais trouvé ça
drôle parce que je l'avais fait il y
avait des médias au québec savez sortie
et les aides
j'avais il y avait trop ce qu'il y en a
vu beaucoup dans l'immédiat puis même
piste a été repris dans l'associé de
prospective mon frère à calgary il
m'appelle il fait nuit retraités dans le
journal de l'histoire des alouettes
marché
mes meilleures affaires gendron de
journal de montréal qui est qui thiam
avec mon gérant
il voulait me parler de tout avec le à
michel a dit j'ai dit non j'ai fait de
la non à ce titre vous qui m'a plu j'ai
juste parlé j'ai fait mais mourir de
stickage fait le plus gros pot de gas de
la planète en ce moment au lieu de faire
crisser un québec taq rachiki ferguene
vous autres vous prenez une france que
c'est un anecdote que j'ai racontée dans
mon potager raconté de chaque jour il
faut à chaque fois maintenant lily je
lis qu'on t'aide à troisvierges c'est
devenu comme une de mes anecdotes de
podcasts dirais cela au lieu de faire si
vous êtes obligés de délaisser malade
fait sommet russe par les impôts ou ou
par les cas l'homme écrit ceci c'est un
accomplissement et non moins de six
tests c'est d'arriver à quelque part
c'est fou mais allez c'est parti tout
est devenu du clic beh web bâtisseur la
problématique
- ouais c'était quoi le cette école
langue de l'entrevue c'est lui qui
parlait liberté d'expression c'est chaud
moi je pense à la façon je me suis fait
boukella c'est le producteur de notre
show à campo médias il y avait et celui
qui nous au pitch et pour faire
augmenter en fait ça de la justice chez
moi lomé a maintenu comme hier certains
livres la semaine d'après texte est pour
faire comme un push de campagne il y
avait moins piquante à l'afp hervé robin
est ce que j'avais combien il y avait 1
je pense arenberg qu'un show a confirmé
via s'il l'a fait wolf a fait qu c'était
pour parler comme un médium et robin la
seule raison qui me voulait c'est
vraiment mon procès que ça l'élise
maurice américain ça les fait capoter
l'autre parce que c'est un humoriste qui
se fanent encore pour un gag par son
gouvernement
c'est sur l'échelle des choses mauvaises
c'est possible avec sow mais pour un
stand up c'est c'la fallait plus peur
j'ai remarqué t à elie le fait de 9 à
rhamna qu'au match mas pas servi de ma
carrière mais je suis devenu comme quand
ma fille m'a donné une crédibilité que
j'avais peur comme fetison quartier tard
il ne savait pas s'ils étaient capables
râpé mais le fait que c'était fait
shooter allemand faisait aux crises
aussi devrait quand même ce qu'il fait
lui les gains que j'ai vraiment senti
sauter la led pour la dernière fois mais
la fois van roekeghem quand j'allais à
et les hostoak mettons un ami par les
plaintes présentées il faisait et c'est
lui le gosse qu'on parlait l'autre plat
ça venait tout autour de moins pour dix
ans vous ne verrez jamais mais j'avais
d'ailleurs elle a redit à fait à chris
et toi acide jeune karima par le gym qui
parle de moi soc voyant sa survie nous
avons connu si jim karim vous et dire
aucune des ch'tis mais chez qui parle
d'un - connaîtront qui manque aux noms
mais dans ces petits partis assez mal à
la tentation du christ voudrais que ma
carrière aux states tous deux fois plus
mais löw n'ont pas
vous même je veux pas devenir
l'humoriste qui je sors moi puis mélo
par exemple de 5,6 jeune belge ondd
humoristiquement je pense je vais faire
une pause avec mon manteau noir où je
vole monte en anglais - qui je vaux
j'attends encore m'ont mis mes papiers
américains écrit j'ai pas été chanceux
parce qu'en te promettons ou un truc
travailler là bas ça de 33 référence
mais trois références j'avais me gilbert
rozon qui j'avais mis un rôle fumée qui
est un américain qui est mort éjecté
dans mis trois références il ya un
prédateur sexuel puis un cada l'autre
c'était le président du festival à
montreux en suisse que j'avais je
m'étais dit je veux la jouer au ballon
puis pilot affecté dans un mort un
prédateur sexuel 28 ski le pays
quittant la le plus les prédateurs
sexuels et que j'ai juste l'un d'un ego
c'est pas prêt mais google hugo qui
blessent les enfants avec ninja qui
mitcham céder via leur excellent travail
pour ericsson a laissé ses clubs alors
qu ils vont accepter les mexicaines ont
été les meilleurs gains avec les plus
mauvaises récoltes en partie maurice
arrive en job du google suit le poggio
jeta un homme qui est un homme qui lit
des enfants du caté chi chi chi chang
losc à bannac jeunes des déchets sauf
que je respecte les animaux j'ai juste
fait les animaux j'allais justement de
là dessus j'ai dit était l'exemple exact
de lentilles spéciste ont été plumés
chien avec résultats avec les animaux
parce que les animaux sont plus fins
glissement non non non ça dépend des
animaux et mes seins parce que les
animaux qui sont foncièrement méchant il
ya des animaux qui pense juste à eux de
jeu
les humains notre qualité c'est qu'on
est bon travail en groupe puis les
animaux il y en a qui travaillent en
groupe mais je trouve y en a aucun qui
travaille aussi bien que nous autres
c'est peut-être le fait aussi qu'on est
capable de parler le talent de babouins
face mais dominent les chiens qu'artiste
un animal tellement gentil mais un chien
pense mais il pense plus à son maître
car n'importe quoi mais il va du jaloux
d'autres chiens puis un chien aidera pas
un autre chien qui connaît pas tandis
qu'un humain si souvent quelqu'un
souffrir tout va l'aider mais même la
pire personne à audubon témoin chic
repense je crois pas qu'il ya quelqu'un
de vraiment bon je crois pas que
vraiment du monde vraiment mauvais il ya
du monde qui sont lyon plus de côtés
négatifs l'autre mais même le pire mme
soirs en syrie doit avoir des petites
côté positif qui même le maire humains
ou la mère humaine est un peu marre des
formats thérése autre que à abbey nice
et lille mardi abby nice et lille i les
hindous sur leur lit de mort à adja
assesseurs même été mettez de l'eau sera
sur son front puis dit à la famille
s'est vu qu'hier chaud mais bennie c'est
le pur pour qu'ils rentrent au paradis
est la fusée sont bien faits mais le
pauvre go et était hindou toute sa
qualité de vie que l'eau dernière
menottes qui devient catholique par
madame surtout si moi je suis athée mais
si les portes de dons par addiction
l'europe non s'il
dieu existe qui sait le un des dieux
hindous que c'est ces soldats dieu lui
était il y avait son équipe de la porte
à fermer aussi mettons toutes les dieux
sont vraies lui y sera mans ceci à un
paradis qui connaît aucun des inside
devant pareil à chelsea j'ai agi comme
versailles pour l'éternité laissé en
tabarnak
mais je reçois avec des amis de ma
blonde que je connais pas les inside je
trouve selon il ya jamais mangé de
vaches veaux cet évier pas végétarien la
terrible ec2 et barbecue est vrai qu'il
y ait fini sol ça arrive
on invite le monde à les bretons jouent
allé voir mon show longs mois je suis en
résidence au club soda
puis après je reviens pas fait qu' il
reste juste ça est ce soir au club soda
ou en fait pas s'asseoir mais c'est
chaud après si je mens vent a tourné en
un an qui a je vais peut-être revenir à
montréal afin complètement ça je le sais
pas encore ça va dépendre si le soleil
est encore le fun oui je reviendrai poti
l'île maurice fond tout le temps aux
trois mois sont à montréal - c'est là où
j'ai mais qui le rejet mais il va
peut-être atteint 1 90 m
mais une aux dattes sidattes besoins des
affaires sous écoute disponible partout
que vous écoutez vos pas de casse dans
notre pays en deux pièces trois pièces
saint piat spolie live
je suis très heureux grâce à vous la
sopat rayon s cré ce jeu me sa chatte
obèse quelque chose loin mais puis on
attend on a changé nos caméras on ne
résiste on réinvestit tout dans le
podcast mais en fait non mais vu qu'au
début ça m'avait coûté une fortune dans
leur entraîneur femmes en noir la
qualité de l'eau la seule afin qu'ils
pokal itélé ses notes éclairage je veux
pas éclairé tout comme vous autres c'est
super bien éclairés ont éclairé qualité
télé mais nous aurons vu que c'est un
show pas si on éclaire qualité télé on
va perdre de coin fait que l'éclairage
voracité oui
yes merci beaucoup d'avoir déjà merci
parcoul yes
[Musique]